So, da bin ich.
Pog Subscription.
Dankeschön.
Massive Sub.
33 Monate wird mal Zeit bald für neue Emotes.
Sage ich schon seit 2 Jahren.
Easy.
Schmoll Access Point auch am Start.
Nice.
So, ich mach mal meine VM an.
Arch, by the way.
Ein paar Package-Updates.
Boah, ey, mir tun die Oberschenkel weh.
Ich bin heute zum ersten Mal.
Alfred, danke für den Sub.
Bin da zum ersten Mal eine Runde knapp 2 Stunden gefahren mit Klickpedalen.
Hab ich schon eine Weile am Start.
Also Klickpedale mit Wattmesser drin.
Hab ich mir schon vor einer Weile gekauft.
Hatte ich bisher nie irgendwie die Muße, das dran zu machen.
Ich hab ein bisschen Umgewöhnung.
Erstens, weil man jetzt permanent auf die Wattzahlen guckt.
Und weil es sich auch irgendwie anders fährt.
Musste gleich den Sattel noch einen Zentimeter hoch machen.
Hat aber auch...
Hat aber auch irgendwie was Praktisches.
Ich weiß noch nicht, was ich davon halte.
Muss mich da erst noch dran gewöhnen, ob mir das gefällt oder nicht.
Was mir gefällt, ist, dass man den Power-Output sieht, ja.
Das ist nice.
Die Schuhe.
Das Geklicke.
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich bin noch etwas skeptisch.
Was macht die Arbeit?
Ja, alles, alles extremely easy.
Ich hab festgestellt,
die Komplexität bei mir auf der Arbeit kommt nicht daher,
dass die einzelnen Sachen so kompliziert sind,
sondern dass es so viel unterschiedlichen Shit gibt.
Vor allem teilweise Legacy-Zeug.
Das ist so Legacy,
dass wahrscheinlich die Entwickler schon gestorben sind mittlerweile.
So Legacy ist das.
Gibt so viel Zeug.
Ich muss aber mittlerweile echt sagen,
ich ignoriere einfach 90% der Sachen,
die mich nicht betreffen.
Sonst kriegst du das alles gar nicht mehr ins...
in den Kopf rein.
Habt ihr eine...
Ja.
Ja, ja.
Wir haben sogar nicht nur eine Entwicklungsabteilung.
Also, Abteilung ja, Abteilung ja,
aber wir haben unterschiedlichsten Eigenentwicklungen.
Wir sind ein Riesenladen.
Ich glaube, wir haben über 1000 Mitarbeiter.
Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht genau, wie viel es wirklich...
wie viel es jetzt konkret sind, aber...
Also alles, alles zusammen müssten wir locker, locker über 1000 haben.
Und selbst wenn wir nur mal den Standort Frankfurt
nimmt, ich meine, ich kann es euch jetzt nicht sagen,
sonst wisst ihr sofort, was es ist.
Allein schon, was die ganzen Gebäude da fassen, ey.
Reaction Jan, danke schön für den Sub.
Zeit zu reacten.
Also, je nachdem, wie da was ist,
ist das auch abteilungsübergreifend.
Also ich bin ja in einem Projekt, wo es um Blockchain
und Kryptotechnologien geht.
Ja, die Frankfurter Finanzbranche hat das jetzt auch spitz gekriegt,
nachdem der Hype schon wieder rum ist.
Aber gut, irgendwann müssen sie ja mal damit anfangen.
Und das war auch schon öfters in den News und alles.
Aber wie gesagt, genau kann ich es euch nicht erzählen.
Ihr wisst sofort, wo ich bin.
Und da haben wir auch alles zusammen in dem Projekt.
Ja, wir klaffen.
Wir haben Infrastrukturleute, wir haben Organisationsleute,
wir haben Leute, die sich mit Krypto-Anwendungskrempel auskennen,
unterschiedlichsten Leute am Start.
Das ist eigentlich ganz nice.
Mir gefällt das.
Mir gefällt das echt.
Also, das ist auch dadurch so schön übergreifend.
Also, ganz ehrlich, ich wäre potenziell überall hingegangen
von der Branche her, sofern halt die Bedingungen gestimmt hätten.
Ja, also sprich, nee, nee, nee, nee, die machen zumindest
auf seriös bei uns, die Krypto-Leute.
Ist ja auch viel Business to Business dabei.
Wenn ihr wüsstet, wie viele Finanzdienstleute
in Frankfurt ihre eigene Blockchain-Suppe kochen
und jetzt miteinander collaboraten wollen
und alle hoffen, dass sie irgendwas Geiles sich ausgedacht haben.
Ja, also, ich habe jetzt nicht konkret nur nach Finanzbranche geguckt.
Ich meine, ich habe es euch ja erzählt.
Ich hatte einen Vertrag schon fast unterschrieben
bei so einer, ja, in Würzburg, glaube ich, war das, bei so einer,
ja, sage ich jetzt nicht.
Aber kein Finanzdienstleiter.
Bei so einer, wie viel, welche Branche ist das so?
Internet und Shopping vielleicht.
Ja, da hätte ich fast unterschrieben.
Ich hatte den Vertrag schon in der Post.
Es ist Stellenanzeigen geschrieben 2.0.
Wenn ihr was habt, was ich mir angucken soll,
ja, kannst du, kannst du alles, kannst posten.
Ich habe aber noch welche, die muss ich mir zuerst angucken.
Also, ihr seht, ich habe hier noch ein paar offen.
Die sind übrig geblieben vom letzten Mal.
Die müssen wir uns heute angucken.
Das ist auch der Grund, warum es in einem Monat zwei Streams gibt.
Weil ich letztes Mal auch erst um 20 Uhr angefangen habe.
Und da haben wir einfach nicht alles durchgekriegt.
Ja.
Also, ich wäre auch potenziell woanders hingegangen,
sofern halt die Bedingungen gestimmt hätten.
Also, sprich, Homeoffice-Möglichkeit, das ist ganz wichtig,
weil Bahn mache ich einfach, kann ich mir, kann ich nicht mehr.
Das ist, das kostet mir zu viel.
Also, das kostet nicht nur an sich Lebenszeit,
dadurch, dass man für alles länger braucht mit der Bahn.
Aber das kostet wirklich Lebenszeit durch, äh,
äh,
psychische Belastung, die Bahn zu benutzen.
Das ist jetzt nicht übertrieben, ja.
Das ist komplett unusable, unterirdischer Kram überhaupt.
Also, das ist, mir fällt da eigentlich gar nichts mehr zu ein.
Hast du ein Auto?
Ja, habe ich.
Ich habe ein Fiat 500e.
Erst letztes Jahr, nee.
Letztes Jahr?
Oh, letztes Jahr gekauft.
Ja, also, Homeoffice ist für mich enorm wichtig.
Teilzeit arbeiten können,
ist für mich, äh,
ach, ja, ich habe übrigens sogar mal bei euch was bestellt.
Irgendwann in letzter Zeit.
Ich weiß nicht mal genau was, aber ich glaube,
was habe ich denn bei euch bestellt?
Ich weiß es gar nicht genau.
Ich glaube, ein Fahrrad, ja, ja, ein Licht, ein Licht,
für vorne zu meinem Lenker, äh, klipsen.
Also, Sachen, die ihr das letzte Mal schon gepostet habt,
müsst ihr nicht nochmal posten, wobei, nee, das hatten wir, hatten wir nicht.
Ja, und, ja, also, wie, wie gesagt, mir ist, mir ist wichtig,
dass es Homeoffice-Möglichkeiten gibt.
Mir ist wichtig, dass ich weiter Teilzeit arbeiten kann.
Ah, haben wir das nicht das letzte Mal schon?
Es kommt mir irgendwie bekannt vor.
Und, äh, im Endeffekt halt auch, dass die Kohle stimmt, ja.
Dann wäre ich auch woanders hingegangen,
wenn mir das besser gefallen hätte.
Klar, warum nicht?
Der, der hätte dir aber früher kommen müssen, als mein letztes Mal.
Naja, ich bin, ich bin ein Plastiker, Arbeitgeber,
weil das war super dr-... Letzten-Drucker-mäßig.
Ich meine, ich habe den Vertrag zu Weihnachten
unterschrieben und in der Po-...
Die endgültige Zusage, dass es 100-prozentig klappt,
auch mit Betriebsrat, Zustimmung und allem,
plus Vertrag.... Das hatte ich an Weihnachten.
Das weiß ich noch. Ich hatte es an, an, äh,
oder einen Tag vor Weihnachten oder so,
Und ich hätte spätestens Ende des Jahres kündigen müssen
Also glaubt mir, das war wirklich knapp
Knapper hätte es nicht sein können
Das war auch sehr anstrengend
Vor quasi dann
Nicht letztes Weihnachten, das Weihnachten davor
Der Dezember, da war es sehr anstrengend
Und nervenaufreibend
Wegen Jobsuche
Und auf den letzten Drücker
Und kommt es noch rechtzeitig an
Und alles, ja
Man muss den aber zugute halten
Die Personalabteilung bei uns ist echt nicht übel
Also in der alten Firma, wo ich gearbeitet hätte
Hätten die das nicht im Leben
Nicht hingekriegt
Das alles innerhalb von quasi
Eineinhalb Wochen zu regeln
Im Leben nicht
Die hätten eineinhalb Wochen gebraucht, bis sie sich geistig sortiert hätten
Was jetzt eigentlich Sache ist
Also, die sind da wirklich nicht
Nicht schlecht, das muss ich sagen
Das hat auch gleich bei mir positiven Eindruck hinterlassen
Dass die wohl wissen, was sie machen
Ich mach mal mal kurz hier Package-Updates
Über allem
Aber wie gesagt, ich wäre auch mal anders hingegangen
Wenn die Sachen gestimmt hätten
Ja, was, auf fünf Tage
Warum denn auf fünf Tage?
Da hast du ja gar nicht so wirklich viel von
Also jeder, wie es ihm am besten gefällt
Aber ein Tag die Woche nicht hin
Ist doch eigentlich viel nicer als
Nur, was ist das da, nur sechs Stunden
Über fünf Tage
Weil ich mein
Ob man jetzt irgendwie 14 Uhr oder 16 Uhr
Oder 15.30 Uhr oder so abhaut
Das macht so einen großen Unterschied
Dann lieber ein Tag nicht da
Aber es ist Geschmackssache
Es gibt ja auch Leute, die verstehen nicht, wie man montags nehmen kann
Und manche sagen, oh ja
Ich würde eigentlich immer Mittwoch so noch nehmen
So einen Tag in der Mitte
Es macht auf jeden Fall einen riesen Unterschied
Ja, ja
Ich kann es auch nur jedem empfehlen
Webentwickler E-Commerce
Weiß ich nicht
Also siehst du die hier oben noch?
Ja, ne, ne, die haben wir noch nicht gemacht
Da können wir damit anfangen
Wenn du jetzt da bist
Und das letzte Mal
Wobei, ne, wir müssen mit einer anderen Stellenanzeige anfangen
Weil ich gesagt habe, wir fangen mit der an
Nämlich mit
IT-Jobs an der Universität Mainz
Das hat letztes Mal schon einer gepostet
Und ich habe gesagt, wir machen die das nächste Mal beim Streamstart
Also ich kann das wirklich jedem nur ans Herz legen
Wer das finanziell
Aushält
Verkraften kann
20% weniger Geld zu kriegen
Es ist
Die 20%
Gehaltseinbuße
Wenn man halt jetzt damit
Über die Runden kommt
Auf jeden Fall wert
Und das ist
Weniger arbeiten zu müssen
Die Zeit, die ihr mehr habt
Ist mehr wert
Als die 20%
Und es gibt eine Sache
Die klingt so banal
Die realisieren aber viele Leute nicht
Wenn es um das Thema Teilzeit geht
Überlegt euch mal
Normal arbeitet ihr 5 Tage
Und habt ihr 2 Tage frei
Wenn ihr nur 4 Tage arbeitet
Dann habt ihr 4 Tage
Und 3 Tage frei
Aber danach habt ihr nur 4 Tage frei
Danach sind es aber auch nur
Also wisst ihr
Danach sind es auch wieder nur 4 Tage
Also sprich es ist nicht nur
Dass ihr einen Tag weniger arbeitet
Sondern ihr habt noch einen Tag mehr frei
Das ist quasi doppelt Vorteil
Und nach diesen 3 Tagen
Müsst ihr wieder nur 4 Tage arbeiten
Bis es wieder 3 Tage frei gibt
In Prozent ist das am besten
Wenn man das in Prozent ausrechnet
Sieht man, dass man quasi dann schon
Von ja was weiß ich
80, 20 oder
70, 30 oder so
Ich weiß es gar nicht
Ich kann euch gar nicht sagen
Was das in Prozent ist
Zumindest
Wenn ihr euch überlegt
Ein weiterer Tag wäre dann schon
Mehr frei als arbeiten
3 Tage Woche
3 Tage Woche bedeutet
3 Tage arbeiten, 4 Tage frei
Das ist genauso die Grenze
Und das lohnt sich
Wirklich richtig
Vor allem
Dadurch, dass
Also wenn man das so macht wie ich
Dadurch, dass man den Tag
Man könnte
Ja, aber ganz ehrlich
Einen Nebenjob würde ich nicht machen
Dann würde ich lieber
Lieber einen Tag mehr arbeiten
Und mehr Kohle kriegen
Aber
Also wie gesagt
Es ist eh nur für Leute
Die sich das leisten können
Und
Was wollte ich jetzt sagen
Die
Also wenn man so macht wie ich
Dass
Der Tag
In dem man frei hat
Irgendwie auch noch an die
2 freien Tagen vom Wochenende grenzt
Also Freitag oder Montag
Ich kann ja Montag empfehlen
Freitag passiert eh nicht so viel
Das ist der Grund
Warum ich
Meinen freien Tag auf Montag gelegt war
Ist
Erstens Montag sind immer
Alle so übermotiviert
Ne
Und außerdem hatte ich
Ja
Den Plan
Dass ich montags mich dann um
Um Business
Kram kümmern kann
Mach ich ab und zu immer noch
Aber wenig
Wenig Business
Zur Zeit
Und dadurch
Habt ihr auch nicht mal das Problem
Was jeder kennt am Wochenende
So
Freitagabend
Nach der Arbeit
Denkst du
Ja boah geil
Jetzt erstmal hier richtig viel frei
Da bist du aber kaputt
Dann pennst du erstmal aus
Samstags machst du noch ein bisschen was
Was gemacht werden muss
Und im Prinzip
Hast du eigentlich
Erstmal die Zeit
Und dann bist du erst mal
Ab Samstag Nachmittag
Zeit das zu machen
Oder ab Samstag Mittag
Worauf du Bock hast
Und dann pennst du Sonntag nochmal
Und spätestens ab Sonntag Mittag
Denkst du dir so
Oh shit
Wochenende ist ja schon wieder fast rum
Ich muss morgen wieder arbeiten
Also
Du hast quasi
Von den zwei Tagen
Richtig Wochenende
Hast du im Kopf eigentlich
Maximal ein Tag richtig Wochenende
Und dadurch
Wenn du einen Tag länger frei hast
Juckt dich das überhaupt nicht
Dann hast du mindestens zwei Tage
Komplett Wochenende
Weil es dich nicht interessiert
Und Montag
Ist auch nicht schlimm
Weil du denkst
Ey
Dreh da drauf an
Tag am Stück frei
Chill ich heute nochmal
Ein bisschen
Ab
Und
Mich juckt überhaupt nicht
Ob es Dienstag weiter geht
Also was sagst du
Du machst im Endeffekt
Aus einem Tag
Wochenende
So von
Entspanntheitsgrad her
Fast drei Tage
Mit einfach
Das ist ein riesen Unterschied
Ja
Teilzeit skaliert
Dreidimensional
Raumzeitskalierung
So
Die vor allem brauchen wir heute gar nicht
Fällt mir aus
Was macht der Pepo eigentlich
Max FPS
Gucken wie macht er das denn
Der macht auch gerade
Gar keine
Videos mehr
Aber es wird mir echt Zeit
Ich werde sogar schon auf Teams
Auf der Arbeit angeschrieben
Ob ich jetzt endlich mal wieder
Ein Video mache
Ja die schwätzen
So viel dumm Zeug
Wenn der Tag lang ist
Dann machen die Leute nicht mit
Macht
Kann es ja keiner zu zwingen
Vertrag ist Vertrag
So
Die VM brauche ich nicht
Let's go
Würde ich sagen
Wo habe ich gesagt
Fangen wir an
Ja
An der Sache
Bei
ID Jobs
An der
An der Sache
So Uni
IT Jobs
Das weiß ich
Ich habe da so ein bisschen
Das Vorurteil dagegen
Dass die alle immer übelst
Sacken
Von Redaktion 1
Okay
Nice
Ist nicht einfach irgendeine Redaktion
Das ist Redaktion 1
Quasi die beste
Die erste
Guck das habe ich auf
Aber ich auf
Habe ich in Teams bekommen
Auf der Arbeit
Mach mal wieder YouTube Video
Weg
Soweit ist es schon
Existierer geführt
Jetzt ab
Ich glaube
Es hat geklopft
Es hat geklopft an der Tür
Moment
Nix
Ne
Müsst man mal ausprobieren
Liegt
Ja
Der, der an der Tür geklopft hat
Weiß jetzt wo ich wohne
Wenn er Stream guckt
Ja
Und was mir heute auch wieder aufgefallen ist
Weil sich ein paar Leute
Ab und zu
Nach dem Stream
Überlegt haben
Wenn ich jetzt
Enkel
Ja
Ich bin
Ja, und was mir heute auch wieder aufgefallen ist, weil sich ein paar Leute, das ist ja witzig, ne, alle ballern sie einen zu mit Meetings und dann beschweren sie sich, wenn du nicht kommen kannst, weil du so viele Paralleltermine hast.
Auf irgendeins musst du dich, kannst ja schlecht auf beide gleichzeitig gehen.
Und mir ist heute mal wieder aufgefallen, so nach dem Motto, 50% Zeit sind nicht 50% Zeit. 50% Zeit sind bei mir erstmal eh schon nur zwei Tage und 50% Zeit heißt nicht 50% Zeit was zu machen, weil das bedeutet 50% von der Restzeit, die man hat, um was zu arbeiten.
Also sprich, wenn alle Organisationssachen erledigt sind, wenn alle Meetings erledigt sind, dann ist bei mir schon auch quasi zwei Tage die Woche.
Ich bin die ganze Woche komplett weg, wenn ich nur Meetings weg mache, ja. Also 50% von meinen 100% sind schon mal mit Gemiete weg, wenn es reicht, wenn es reicht, wahrscheinlich sogar mehr, mehr würde ich sagen.
Und davon die 50% sind noch übrig. Das bedeutet im Endeffekt, wenn die Glück haben, einen Tag.
Ne, also ich habe mich ein paar Mal am Anfang bei meinem Chef beschwert, dass so viel gemietet wird, aber letztendlich mittlerweile denke ich mir, ey, die Firma will das so. Wird auch immer gesagt.
Ganz ehrlich.
Ganz richtig in Meetings. Ich habe damit keine Schmerzen. Es ist nicht so, dass ich da geil drauf bin und da irgendwie mich super freue drüber. Ich hätte es auch gerne anders, aber mittlerweile denke ich mir, juckt mich nicht.
Wenn ihr wollt, dass ich den ganzen Tag miete, ich miete auch. Ihr überweist mir so viel Kohle, wenn ihr mir so viel Kohle überweisen wollt, nur fürs Mieten, ist auch in Ordnung.
Soll mir recht sein. Ja, das ist denen aber egal.
Findest du drei Meetings in der Woche viel? Ne, wenig.
Soll ich dir mal sagen, was ich habe? Passt mal auf.
Ich hoffe, die Woche ist repräsentativ.
Kalender.
So.
Also.
Geht los.
Alter, ist das viel. Meine Güte.
Gestern.
Ich muss das jetzt ein bisschen anonymisieren.
Also, gestern.
Daily Scrum Projekt.
Termin mit unserem neuen Azubi.
Okay, das ist erstmal was Sinnvolles.
Ja.
Äh, Daily.
Team Daily.
CI, CD, Infrastruktur.
Keine Ahnung, was das war. Da war ich nicht.
Ach, Moment.
Ich hab mich verguckt.
Warum zeigt es gestern als Montag an?
Ach so.
Weil gestern Montag war, kann das sein.
Low IQ Teams User.
Okay, Dienstag.
Dienstag.
Schwachsinn.
Ähm.
Okay.
Daily Scrum.
Also, heute. Heute muss ich gucken, ja.
Geht weiter.
Also, Daily Scrum.
Daily Scrum Projekt.
Geht weiter.
Sprint Review Projekt.
Team Daily.
Geht weiter.
Projekt Sprint Retrospektive.
Ähm.
Geht weiter.
Backlog Refinement.
Sprint Planning.
Parallel Termin.
Sure Fix.
Anderer Service.
Parallel Termin.
Sprint Planung.
Anderes Projekt.
Alle, drei, drei Termine.
14.30 Uhr.
Ja, dann, dann war, dann war 15.40 Uhr was, aber da war ich schon weg.
So.
Also, das war heute.
Das heißt, legit, ich habe heute, außer mal eine Stunde mittags mit meinem Kollege,
der sich auch um die, die Services, um die Karte geht,
um die gleichen Services kümmert,
haben wir mal neue Zertifikate beantragt, haben wir nix gemacht.
Wir haben quasi nur Cag, Cag, äh, Cagweight Business gemietet.
So, morgen, guckt, wie es morgen aussieht.
Morgen wird es besser.
So, ne, weiß ich nicht.
Morgen, ähm, wie nenne ich das jetzt, äh, morgen ist so ein Termin, äh, Führungskräfte
stellen neue Sachen vor.
Das heißt ein bisschen anders, aber ich sage euch nicht, wie es genau heißt.
Dann geht es weiter.
Dadys Scrum Projekt.
Da so halb parallel dazu, major fix service, dann ähm Support Meeting mit irgend einem
Dienstleister, der für uns Zeug programmiert, danach ähm Gruppenrunde, danach Teamrunde,
danach haben wir Abteilungsversammlung, ok, hä, fällt mir jetzt auch erst auf.
Und ist das in Präsenz?
Ich hoffe nicht.
Weil, weil, ich weiß nicht, ob das der Fall wäre, bin an Dreh geo, ich hab' so ein bisschen
Ahnung deswegen.
nehme da eh Remote dran teil.
Nee, nee, ist es nicht.
Ist die Teamrunde einfach ein weiteres
Daily? Nee.
Team Daily ist was anderes als Teamrunde.
Die Teamrunde ist einmal die Woche. So, das war morgen.
Also im Prinzip,
also im Prinzip auch wieder den ganzen Tag
nur gemietet. Und morgen
fahre ich nach Frankfurt. Ach so, was ich
vergessen habe. 15 Uhr.
Projekt Sync und Sure Fix.
Aber da bin ich schon längst im Zug und
auf dem Weg heim.
Okay, so. Also, ihr habt gesehen,
das war jetzt zwei Tage,
zwei Tage von dieser
Woche. Ich habe da nicht wirklich
viel gemacht, außer gemietet. So, guck mal mal.
Guck mal mal, ob es besser wird. Donnerstag.
Donnerstag.
Daily Scrum Projekt.
Team Daily
allerdings diesmal 50 Minuten
länger als die Viertelstunde sonst.
50 Minuten, um sich über neue
Themen auszutauschen. Wir haben einmal die Woche ein bisschen länger.
Okay. Einarbeitungsblocker.
Den haben wir drinnen stehen
lassen. Den habe ich mal bekommen, als ich neu angefangen
habe, von einem Kollege. Und wir haben gesagt,
weißt du was? Wir lassen den einfach undefiniert
drinnen stehen, dass wenigstens mal eine Stunde die
Woche geblockt ist für irgendwas.
Einarbeitungsblocker.
Da müssen wir nichts machen.
Wir haben die letzten Male... Wenn man was machen will,
kann man dann was machen.
Sure Fix.
Wöchentlich. Wieder anderes Projekt.
Kubernetes
Team. Sure Fix.
Ähm.
Ja, Blockchain.
Gedöns. Austausch. So. Das war Donnerstag.
Also im Prinzip auch nur gemietet. Wobei,
das stimmt nicht. Kubernetes
Team. Sure Fix ist abgesagt.
Pellt eine halbe Stunde
aus davon. Okay. Also Donnerstag
kann ich vielleicht so eineinhalb
Stunden was machen. Neben Gemiete.
Okay, Freitag. Mal gucken, ob Freitag besser
ist. Freitag
gibt es
drei Stunden irgendeine
Cloud-Präsentation.
Weiß ich nicht, ob ich da dran teilnehme.
Du spielst das Jobsuche-Game.
Sollen wir uns irgendwas angucken?
Ich hab noch... Ich hab Zeit heute. Wobei, so viel Zeit
hab ich gar nicht. So. Danach
Daily Scrum
Projekt. Team Daily.
Dann irgend so was
komisches mit Ansible, wo ich
wahrscheinlich nicht hingehe.
Ja, Freitag. Freitag ist tatsächlich
mal so zwei, drei
Stunden was zu arbeiten möglich.
So. Und das heißt, wenn ich 50%
meiner Zeit was mache, sind das
50% von
dem, was nach dem ganzen
Gemiete noch übrig ist. Das sind nicht
zwei Tage die Woche. Das verstehen die
alle immer falsch. Und dazu
kommt ja natürlich auch noch zig Organisationssachen.
Ich hab teilweise
Frühschicht, wo ich gucken muss, ob es
irgendwelche... Also nicht wirklich Frühschicht,
aber wir haben so eine wechselnde
Sache mit, wer sich vormittags die ganzen
Tickets und Tasks, die reinkommen, angucken.
Das muss ich auch manchmal machen. Da kommen dann im
15-Minuten-Takt irgendwelche Mails und Tickets, die du
zuweisen musst.
Fürs Team.
Dann, ähm, kommen noch irgendwelche
anorganisatorischen Sachen. Da musst du irgendwelche
Pflichtschulungen besuchen und hast du nicht gesehen.
Also es sind ja wirklich 50%
von dem, was übrig bleibt.
Das verstehen die alle immer nicht.
Und das muss man denen, glaube ich, echt mal ein bisschen
öfters sagen, dass 50% nicht
zwei Tage sind, sondern 50% sind
vielleicht, wenn's hochkommt,
ein Tag die Woche. Wenn's hochkommt.
Bei dem ganzen Gemiete wahrscheinlich
eher einen halben Tag. Aber was soll ich
machen? Die wollen das so? Mein Problem
ist es nicht.
Wenn sie damit Probleme haben, dass ich das nicht
machen kann, was sie wollen, dann
müssen sie zu meinem Chef und sich beschweren
und dann darf der sich überlegen, zu welchen Meetings
ich absagen darf.
Er will ja, dass ich da hingehe. Also insofern
mir ist das egal.
Also mittlerweile ist mir das egal.
Kommen wir...
Genau das, genau das denke ich mir auch.
Ich hab's mehrfach gesagt,
aber wenn das Gemiete so Gemiete sein soll
und die Firma das so will, das ist okay.
Die überweisen mir die Kohle, ob ich da was
arbeite richtig für oder ob ich nur miete.
Das ist mir... Am Ende ist es mir egal, ja.
Natürlich würde ich auch lieber
ein paar interessante, technisch interessante Dinger machen.
Nein,
kenn ich mich nicht mit aus.
Okay, dann
schauen wir uns doch mal was an.
Damit hab ich das letzte Mal
gesagt, fangen wir an.
Was haben wir denn hier? Stellenanzeige IT Jobs
an der Universität Mainz. Ja, Redaktion
1. Schönes, nice
Stockfoto im Hintergrund.
Vielleicht aber auch was von denen.
Ich weiß nicht, ich würde mir eher sagen ein Stockfoto.
Warum ist das Bild besser aufgelöst als so?
Was bin ich da sehend?
Ist das ein Mac?
Glaube ich den nicht.
Ich sag mal, das da, Chat, das da oben rechts,
das ist doch noch Sublime Text, oder?
Guckt euch mal das Colorscheme an, das ist Monokai.
Oder Monokai, oder wie das heißt das?
Sublime Text Standard Theme.
Sublime Text Enjoyers, dass es das noch gibt.
Datenprogramm klein.
Okay, Wordpress.
Alles klar.
Gut, was will denn die Un...
Warum ist das so groß?
Was will denn die Universität Mainz?
Sucht IT, fragt er dich.
Jigu.
Johannes Gutenberg Universität.
Ah, das war nicht der, der seine Doktorarbeit gefälscht hat, ne?
Das war der mit dem Buchdruck, glaube ich.
Ihre Karrieremöglichkeiten.
Netzwerk, IT Security, IT System Service.
Ja, okay.
Die Karrieremöglichkeiten umfasst einfach mal alles.
Welche, was wollen sie haben?
Komplett. Alles.
Netzwerk, Security, Systemtechnik, Server Storage, Webentwicklung, Datenbank, Server Virtualisierung.
Das ist egal.
Wir machen alles.
Das IT-Zentrum der Universität.
Okay, blablabla.
Ihr Profil.
Fachbezogene Ausbildung, Studium oder einschlägige Berufserfahrung.
Zuverlässige und verantwortungsbewusste Arbeitsweise.
Sehr gut Deutsch kennengelernt, schrieb mindestens C1 Niveau.
Whatever, habe ich bestimmt nicht.
Ich mache viel zu viele Denglish-Sätze.
Äh, Kommunikation.
Kommunikationsfähigkeit, Freude an Teamarbeit.
Okay.
Kommt auf die Leute an.
Wir leben Diversität.
Das ist schön, aber es ist nicht MWD.
Ja, okay.
Und was wollt ihr jetzt und was macht ihr jetzt?
Arbeitsalltag mit Sinn.
Mit ihrem Einsatz leistet ihr einen wichtigen Beitrag zur Weiterentwicklung der IT für Forschung, Lehre und Studium.
Sichere Arbeitsplätze.
Work-Life-Balance.
Bis 50 Prozent.
Das heißt, du musst schon mal.
50 Prozent ist halt doof bei 5-Tage-Woche.
Das sind 2,5 Tage.
Und ich wette mit euch, die runden das down.
Die sagen dann, ah ja, da machst du halt 2 Tage Homeoffice und kommst 3 Tage her.
Weil 50 Prozent gehen ja nicht auf.
Bis zu 50 Prozent.
In Absprache.
Ja, okay.
Dann sagen die, nachdem man angefangen hat, kein Bock.
Finanzielle Absicherung.
Eingruppierung in den Tarifvertrag für den öffentlichen Dienst.
Je nach Kenntnis, Studium, Ausbildung.
Die Listen habe ich mir mal angeguckt.
Ich blicke da ehrlich gesagt nicht durch.
Welche Stufe und welche, wie das genau funktioniert.
Es ist in der Regel aber nicht gerade üppig.
Ja, das kann man zum Beispiel machen.
Ja, das könnte man machen.
Geregelte Arbeitsbedingungen.
Wow, das ist aber nett von denen.
Überstundenwert.
Moment, Moment, Moment, Leute.
Arbeitszeiterfassung ist Pflicht.
Das ist nicht so, dass das irgendwie.
Random.
Wir machen es einfach mal.
Weiterbildungsangebote.
Gut und günstige Erreichbarkeit.
Okay, ja, das.
Ihre Gesundheit ist uns wichtig.
Ja, was?
Hä?
Was ist denn das für eine bescheuerte Stellenanzeige?
Da steht ja gar nichts drin.
Das steht ja gar nichts drin.
Okay, es steht drin.
Es steht.
Es steht einmal.
So gerne ist so so.
Ja, so breit wie nur irgendwie mögen.
Aber da steht ja gar nichts drin.
Das ist eine mega schlechte Stellenanzeige.
Wir suchen Leute, habe ich.
Ich habe das einzige, was ich jetzt verstanden habe.
Die suchen Leute, die irgendwas mit IT am Hut haben.
Schon seit einer Weile.
Offen sie zumindest.
Ich habe seit neuestem so eine Trinkflasche.
So eine Plastik Trinkflasche, die nicht nach Plastik schmeckt.
Sehr nice.
Hier so immer.
Was hat denn das?
Passt da rein?
Ein Liter.
Auffüllbar.
Neben.
Auf dem Tisch stehen zu haben.
Früher habe ich mir immer Wasser ins Glas geholt und einen Tee und sowas.
Jetzt fülle ich mir einfach paar Mal ab Nacht das Ding hier auf.
So saufe ich auch immer genug Wasser.
Wohlgemerkt.
Also die Stellenanzeige ist schlecht.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass irgendjemand, der wirklich ein bisschen Fähigkeiten hat,
sich dafür interessiert.
Das ist wirklich schlecht.
Das ist eine wirklich schlechte Stellenanzeige.
So, dann gucken wir uns jetzt die Stellenanzeige an.
Von...
Äh, habe ich...
Äh, wo habe ich die denn?
Habe ich die irgendwie gelöscht eben gerade?
Der Web...
Webentwick...
Hä?
Irgendwie S...
Wie heißt das?
Ne, nicht SVA.
Doch, hier.
Webentwickler.
Ne.
Ach ne, da ist er doch.
Okay.
Ja, Flashbang.
Da...
Du arbeitest da?
Bist du...
Bist du für Recruiting zu tun?
Ja.
Okay.
Bist du für Recruiting zuständig?
Also...
Weil, wenn...
Wenn nicht, ist egal.
Dann kann ich jetzt hier richtig schön ablästern.
Okay.
Wo...
Wo sind wir denn eigentlich gelandet?
Ihr Experte für IT-Lösungen.
Okay.
Hat nen guten Ruf.
Ich kenn die nicht.
Also, ich hab keine Ahnung.
Gibt's die in Frankfurt?
Nein, gibt's nicht.
Talente, herzlich willkommen.
Die haben euch consultet.
Okay.
Wiesbaden und Würzburg gibt's die.
Ja.
Also, nicht so weit.
So.
Also.
Was machen sie denn?
Es ist mal wieder ne Stellenanzeige mit erstmal ne halbe Seite Selbstbeweihräucherung.
Du warst in vier Jahren nur einmal im Büro.
Das heißt, wenn die hier was von Homeoffice schreiben, dann stimmt das auch.
Also begeistern sie sich für hochwertige IT...
Okay.
Das können wir skippen.
Als Partner für Zukunfts...
Ja.
Blablabla.
Okay.
Das kann man immer skippen.
Das ist immer die erste halbe Seite Selbstbeweihräucherung.
Okay.
Sie suchen...
Zur Verstärkung unseres Teams...
Ach, guck mal.
Die suchen was für dein Team.
Kann das sein?
Die suchen einen DevOps-Consultant in Kultur und Organ...
Kultur und Organisation.
Verstehe den Zusammenhang dazwischen nicht so ganz, aber...
Okay.
Sie suchen Deutschlandwein, einen DevOps-Consultant in Kultur und Organisation.
MWD.
200-köpfigen Deutschland-Teams bestehen aus DevOps-Ingenieuren.
Ich finde das übrigens toll.
Lass die Ingenieure schreiben.
Und Architekten, Softwareentwicklern und den Experten für Agilität und Transformation
begleiten wir unsere Kunden langfristig.
Ach, das ist so ein Consulting-Laden.
Wir beraten nicht nur auf technologischer, sondern auch auf organisatorischer Ebene,
bei der es insbesondere um Kultur und das Mindset rund um DevOps, Continuous Integration,
Continuous Delivery und Agilität geht.
Das Mindset ist entscheidend, Leute.
Das sagen uns die ganzen Coaches auch immer.
Aber das passt ja.
Das ist so ein Consulting-Laden.
Da geht es ums Mindset.
Das ist einfach nur für High-Performance-Mindset-Sigma-Mail-Consultants.
Wobei, ne, äh, MWD-Consultants.
Ich weiß immer noch nicht, was man als DevOps-Consultant macht, was Kultur...
Aber okay, schauen wir mal, was die haben wollen.
Ich glaube nicht, dass die einen Scrum Master suchen.
Dann würden sie es hinschreiben.
Beratung unserer Kunden bei der Gestaltung von DevOps.
Beratung unserer Kunden bei der Gestaltung von DevSecOps.
Oh, da kann man aber noch ein bisschen, da kann man aber noch ein bisschen, ein bisschen aufdrehen.
Man kann Win bis DevSecFullstackOps.
Kultur und Organisation.
Ich finde es aber mittlerweile, ich finde es eigentlich prinzipiell eine gute Entwicklung,
dass das da mit erwähnt wird mittlerweile.
Kultur und Organisation Begleitung von IT-Projekten im Bereich Continuous Integration, Continuous Deployment.
Ach so, okay.
Okay, das ist Deployment, nicht Delivery.
Ich dachte immer, CD ist Delivery.
Ich bin mir auch ziemlich sicher.
Ich glaube, das ist so ein Ding, damit es schlicht und ergreifend eh das Gleiche gemeint.
Also nennt es jeder ein bisschen anders.
Von der Konzeption bis zur Fertigkeit.
Technologienahe Begleitung bei Transformationsprojekten als Zeil.
Nein, nicht aller Zeiten, als Zeil.
Eine Zusammenarbeit zwischen Kunden und SV-Kollegen im Bereich der...
Ja, das ist sehr vage, sehr vage.
Unterstützung und Leitung der Projektteams.
Wow.
Leitung der Projektteams?
Ich versuche gerade aus der Stellenanzeige irgendwie schlau zu werden.
Was wollen die denn eigentlich haben?
Einsetzen und Coaching von cross-funktionalen Teams und Einzelpersonen bei unseren Kunden als Unterstützung bei der Ausbildung.
Okay, die suchen irgendeinen Consultant, den sie verschachern können.
Der dann dort auf...
Agile Experte macht oder...
Wie?
Das ist so eine...
Es ist aber auch kein Projektmanager.
Ich wäre aus der Stellenanzeige nicht so ganz schlau.
Moderation von Workshops im DevOps-Kontext beim Kunden und SV intern.
Erstellung und aktualisieren technischer Dokumentation.
Siehste, auch wieder was.
Es muss einfach first try immer funktionieren.
Dann braucht man keine Dokumentation.
Weil, man braucht ja nur Dokumentation, wenn es jemand fixen muss, weil es kaputt ist.
Wenn es nie kaputt geht, ist das easy.
Dann brauchen wir auch keine Dokumentation.
Insbesondere im Kontext von CICD-Tools.
DevOps-Projekt-Ingenieur-Unterstützung des Vertriebsteams durch Techniker.
In der Pre-Sales-Phase.
Du sollst auch noch die Sachen irgendwie schmackhaft machen oder so.
Die nehmen dich dann quasi mit auf...
Kennt ihr dieses YouTube-Video The Expert?
Oder Die Expert?
Mal...
Malen sie eine gerade Linie, die schräg ist.
Oder wie das ging.
Kennt ihr, habt ihr das mal gesehen?
Ich glaube, so jemand suchen die.
Äh, nicht Experten.
Ja.
Habt ihr das mal gesehen?
Das ist der Experte.
Der irgendwie zwei parallele Linien malen soll, die nicht parallel sind oder sowas.
Und sie suchen quasi so einen Experten, der mitgeht.
Auf Verkaufsveranstaltungen.
Und dort nicht total abkackt.
Weil das ist echt nicht für jedermann was.
Das bringen sie mit.
Abgeschlossenes...
Oh, Chat, was?
Moment.
Das ist nur bla bla.
Da muss man nur ein bisschen Fernsehpräsentation machen.
Ja, aber es ist...
Also für mich ist aus der Stellenanzeige irgendwie nicht ersichtlich, was die haben wollen.
Ach so.
Ah, du sollst nicht mit, wenn was verkauft wird.
Du sollst im Vorfeld gucken, dass man denen nicht erzählt, das Ding hat einen MP3-Player eingebaut, obwohl es keinen MP3-Player eingebaut hat.
Mehrjährige Beratungserfahrung in IT-Projekten.
Sowie in technischen als auch nicht technischen Rollen.
Idealer durch marktübliche Zertifizierung im Bereich agile Methoden und DevOps.
Okay.
Ihr wisst, ich halte von den meisten Zertifizierungen gar nichts.
Was wäre denn, nur mal so für mich als Noob.
Was wäre denn eine marktübliche Zertifizierung?
Eine marktübliche Zertifizierung im Bereich DevOps.
Was macht man da so?
Ja, die Kubernetes-Einstiegszertifizierung zählt ja wahrscheinlich nicht.
Weil die ist easy, die kriegt jeder mit ein bisschen Üben hin.
Scrum Master...
Nee, CCNA wird es nicht sein.
Was ist...
Ja doch!
Also meinst du doch, dass...
Wenn ich das hier lese, okay.
Also zählt doch...
Die Kubernetes-Zertifizierung.
Sie haben verstanden, dass DevOps effektiv umgesetzt wird, indem man CI, CD-Tools, Kulturaspekte und agile Organisation parallel anpackt.
Chat, haben wir das verstanden?
Ich bin mir da noch nicht ganz sicher.
Sie wissen, was ein Merge, ein Fork, eine Container-Plattform und Infrastructure as Code ist.
Hey, wenigstens mal was mit ein paar Sachen, mit denen ich was anfangen kann.
Und welche organisatorischen Aspekte man anpassen muss, um die Technologien erfolgreich...
Moment.
Wie setzt man einen...
Wie setzt man einen Merge...
Erfolgreich ein?
Äh...
What?
Da haben doch auch wieder Leute die Stellenanzeigen geschrieben, die auch nicht so genau wissen, was da reinschreiben, oder?
Wenn du jetzt Zertifikate machst, wenn die bezahlt sind, das finde ich gut.
Erfahrungen im folgenden Bereich wünschen zu der Softwareentwicklung, Container...
Shit.
Repos.
Container-Technologien.
Secret-Management.
Analytische Ausgib...
DevOps-Tools für verschiedene Hersteller.
Also man kann...
Weißt du, man kann Jira bedienen, oder?
Äh...
Oder...
Oder man hat schon mal ein Jenkins-Workflow angelegt, oder GitHub-Actions, oder was weiß ich.
Ausgeprägte Kundenentwicklung.
Soziale Kompetenz.
Okay, da fallen die meisten Leute, inklusive mir, schon mal durch.
Sie arbeiten gerne im Team.
Gute Kommunikationsfähigkeit.
Eine Reisemannschaft.
AI...
Na gut, das ist halt so eine Berater... Beraterbude da.
Ist das normal?
Darauf können sie sich freuen.
Arbeitszeiten, die zu übernehmen.
Ein tolles Team.
Moderne Arbeit mit dem Notebook.
Ist...
Habt ihr freie Betriebssystemwahl auf dem Notebook für solche Leute?
Falls ja...
Würde ich das unbedingt reinschreiben in die Stellenanzeige.
Das wäre für mich ein riesen Pluspunkt.
Viele Möglichkeiten...
Also...
Das ist eh nichts für mich, aber...
Also das...
Das...
Könntest du echt denen, die diese Stellenanzeigen schreiben, sagen.
Freie Betriebssystemauswahl.
Ist ein mega Pluspunkt.
Wenn man das hat.
Das auch reinzuschreiben.
Viele Möglichkeiten, sich weiterzubilden.
Boden...
Was?
Bodenhaft?
Moment.
Ein inhabergeführtes, unabhängiges Unternehmen mit Bodenhaftung.
Was soll das überhaupt bedeuten?
Und hoher Servicequalität.
Selbständiges Arbeiten und Raum für Eigenverantwortung.
Okay.
Also...
Jetzt haben wir hier so zwei Sachen, die so ein bisschen konflikten.
Und zwar...
Also...
was man sieht und den ersten Eindruck,
den man hat. Und ich fand die
jetzt nicht so tolle.
Es wirkte sehr allgemein.
Und ich hatte den
Eindruck, dass
die Leute, die die Stellenanzeige geschrieben haben,
eigentlich gar keine Ahnung genauer haben,
was das jeweilige Team sucht.
Weil ansonsten
es ist ein bisschen durcheinander.
Ein bisschen Projekt,
ein bisschen sollst du dann aber auch doch entwickeln
und was machen.
Dann sollst du eine gute Figur machen,
um Zeug zu verkaufen
bei irgendwelchen Kunden.
Also richtiges Bild kann ich mir
davon jetzt nicht machen.
Bullshitanzeige, ja.
Also wenn die wirklich wollen, dass sich jemand meldet,
dann würde ich eine bessere Stellenanzeige reinschreiben.
Das ist der sicherste Weg,
jemanden zu finden.
Also mich persönlich
würde es jetzt nicht ansprechen.
Ich glaube dir aber,
dass das ein guter Laden ist.
Und ich hatte,
wir haben sogar zwei Leute gehandelt,
gehabt im Stream.
Die,
einer hatte die hier quasi als Consultants bei sich im Laden
und die waren nicht schlecht
und wir haben einen, der dort arbeitet im Stream.
Also beide sagen, die taugen was.
Die Stellenanzeige selbst alleine
finde ich jetzt nicht so überzeugend.
Okay, next.
Was haben wir denn sonst hier noch?
Wir machen erstmal die noch auf,
die wir vom letzten Mal hier drin haben.
Hatten wir das nicht schon?
Das war deine?
Ich dachte, das hier war deine.
Oder beides deine?
Macht ihr eigentlich was in Richtung ChatOps?
Das ist auch so ein Wort.
Was verstehst du unter ChatOps?
Meinst du, dass dein Monitoring
in den Teams Channel postet,
wenn was kaputt ist?
Oder dass du sagen kannst,
slash deploy?
Oder was ist für dich ChatOps?
Ne, die habe ich glaube ich nicht gesehen.
Die ist aber auch
sehr hell, die Webseite.
Ja, das haben wir.
Das haben wir.
Chat benachrichtigen, wenn sowas ist.
Aber du kannst bei uns nicht aus dem Teams Channel
irgendwas deployen oder so.
Auf der anderen Seite, ich finde das auch,
das ist overrated.
Ob du jetzt beispielsweise im
Ansible Webinterface klickst und irgendeinen Job
ausführst oder in irgendeinem
CI-CD-Tool klickst oder ob du im Chat
schreibst, slash deploy
das dahin.
Ach ja, ich find's
jetzt macht keinen so großen Unterschied.
Was ganz nice ist,
ist halt für so Status-Feeds,
dass das gesamte Team das sieht.
Okay, also.
SHD.
Wer ist?
Die Webseite
ist ein bisschen pp-iger, lass mich mal kurz checken,
ob's am Darkreader liegt.
Ne, oder?
Soll das so?
Sieht irgendwie kaputt aus.
Ja, aber bei einem Hamburger Menü erwarte
ich entweder ein seitliches Menü, irgendwie sieht's
komisch aus, aber das ist wahrscheinlich so gewollt.
Okay.
Webentwickler im E-Commerce
Bereich. Hybrid.
Ach ja! Übrigens, hier.
SVA. Hier steht nix von
Homeoffice drinne. Und du sagst, das ist
bei dir, ja quasi
gang und gäbe. Das würd ich auch auf
jeden Fall reinschreiben.
Das ist so ne typische Stellenanzeige, wo ich
denke, jetzt nach dem, was ihr gesagt habt,
der Laden ist eigentlich ganz gut, aber die verkaufen sich
nicht gut in der Stellenanzeige.
Ja. Auf schlechtem Monitoren ist
der Kontrast hier. Nicht Webentwickler,
Designer. Sie sind doch, sie sind doch
Webentwickler, kein Webdesigner, also.
Also sie bräuchten vielleicht
ein paar Webdesigner.
Aber geht, geht klar. Moment, ich muss Darkreader wieder
anmachen. Also es lag nicht am Darkreader bei mir.
Also.
Äh, SAD Einzelhandel
Software GmbH sucht
dich zum nächstmöglichen Zeitpunkt.
Okay, also. Was wollen sie denn
haben? Entwicklung und Implementierung einer
benutzerfreundlichen E-Commerce Lösung bei
unseren Kunden aus der Möbelbranche.
Kann jetzt auch irgendwie alles und nichts
sein, ja?
Was war das mit der Teams-Nachricht? Deine Kollegen wollten
ein neues YouTube-Video, ja?
Ja. Hab ich in Teams gekriegt,
die Nachricht.
Kennt jemand eine gute Stellenanzeige
als .NET-Entwickler? Äh, hatten wir
bisher noch nicht.
Aber ich mag .NET.
Exposed, ja.
Mich haben ein paar erkannt
auf der Arbeit, als ich da angefangen hab.
Vor allem ein paar Jüngere.
Die haben wahrscheinlich früher Call of Duty-Videos
oder so geguckt, weiß nicht.
An's Trinken erinnern. Ja, mach ich. Ich hab so
eine Liter Trinkflasche hier stehen.
Also, was wollen sie denn
haben? Entwicklung im Playground, okay.
Optimierung der Shop-Lösung unserer Kunden
für eine reibungslose Benutzervereinbarung und
maximale Conversions. Jawoll!
Big stonks
money. Entwicklung
von innovativen Funktionen, Features,
Prüfung der Trends, kontinuierliche
Verbesserung, Monitoring, Analyse
der Website, Optimierungsportale,
Potentialerkennung, Dokumentation von neuen
Entwicklungen. Schon wieder so Dokumentationsleute.
Ich sag,
ich, ich, ich, ich glaube,
ich muss auch Consultant werden.
Und errorless
Programming
unter die Leute bringen.
Und dann braucht man,
guck mal, wie viel Zeit man hat, wenn man nix
dokumentieren muss. Keine Dokumentation,
keine Tests, keine
Comments schreiben.
Und das alles nur, weil's einfach funktioniert.
Ist doch easy. Ich versteh nicht, warum da nicht schon
so viel früher jemand drauf gekommen ist.
Keine Ahnung.
Dieses Team erwartet dich. Gestalte
mit uns die Zukunft des Digital
Commerce.
In unserem Team aus neun kreativen Köpfen,
die die digitale Welt verstehen. Möbelbranche,
enthusiastische Truppe. Okay.
Die gemeinsam die Grenzen
verschiebt. Dann komm zu uns.
Du, so überzeugst
du. Mich würde jetzt erst einmal
vor allem interessieren, was die eigentlich haben wollen.
Beziehungsweise so, was die denn
eigentlich einsetzen. Weil ich mein, E-Commerce,
Möbel,
das ist so. Vielleicht kommt das ja noch.
Ja, jetzt, jetzt
kommen noch ein paar Sachen. Okay.
Leidenschaft für Webentwicklung. Mehr als alles
andere brennst du für die
Erstellung und Optimierung von
E-Commerce-Plattformen. Du bist neugierig,
experimentierfreudig, stets auf der Suche
nach der nächsten Herausforderung in der digitalen
Welt. Erfahrung mit Shopware 6.
Okay. Keine Ahnung, was Shopware 6 ist.
Ist das auf PHP-Basis?
Ja!
Wie ich's wieder wusste.
So, lasst uns mal kurz
checken. Release
History. Von wann ist Version 6?
Version 6? Mai 2019.
Okay, das ist ja noch quasi wie neu.
Ja, ich mag dieses
du brennst für und so diese Formulierung.
Find ich auch blöd.
Shops ist doch zu 90%
PHP.
Ja, das kommt aber auch aus historischer
Sicht und, und das darf
man nicht unterschätzen, auch in der
heutigen Zeit. Ups.
Wollt ich gleich zeigen.
Viele dieser Shop-Software-Dinger
zählen ja auch auf Leute ab, die
sagen wir mal, Semiplan haben.
Die sich irgendwie in
Webspace kaufen wollen und
es gibt halt, egal wo man
ein bisschen Webstorage oder
Webspace kauft und überall
gibt's PHP. Ja, du
findest dort kein .net
oder sonst irgendwie was
im Backend. Du findest aber PHP.
PHP hat jeder Feld, Wald und Wiese
0815 Billighaus da.
Okay. Ja, warum man das heute
eben, ja, ja, weil's halt überall läuft.
Zumindest auch aus historischer Sicht.
Ansonsten, warum man das heute
noch so macht, gibt ja, es gibt ja mehr
Möglichkeiten als
irgendwo bei
Strato-Webspace kaufen.
Ich weiß eh nicht, warum man das macht. Man kann sich
einfach eine Linux-VM mieten. Gut, das kriegen die
meisten Leute halt dann nicht hin damit.
Okay, Shopware 6. Kein Plassen.
Technische Skills.
Du verfügst über umfangreiche Kenntnisse in
PHP,
Node.js, Bootstrap,
CSS, Sass,
Twig.
Was ist das?
Aha.
Ach, das ist,
ah, das ist eine Template Engine.
War das, war das nicht früher
Smarty bei PHP?
Gab es nicht sowas, PHP Smarty?
Smarty gibt's auch, okay.
Vue.js,
Symfony, TypeScript,
Teamplayer
mit Kommunikationstalent.
Sprachkenntnisse.
Offen für
Quereinsteiger. Wir wissen das. Großartige
Fähigkeiten nicht. Okay.
Das kannst du erwarten. Agiles
und flexibles Arbeiten.
Ja.
ETC ist halt
immer geil, ne? Ja, wir benutzen
das, das, das, das und ansonsten auch.
Denkt ihr einfach was.
Persönliche Wachstumschancen, modernes
Arbeitsumfeld im Büropark.
Aha.
Erhalte eine Vergütung,
die deine Leistung würdigt, inklusive
Urlaubsimpfung. Bedeutet das, ich bekomme
normalerweise so wenig und wenn ich keinen Bonus
kriege, reicht's nicht auf?
Ne, das ist damit glaube ich nicht gemeint.
Wisst ihr,
es ist
so blöd, dass
sich das nicht mit der Zeit mal irgendwie etabliert,
dass sie zumindest eine Range posten.
Ich seh's
in letzter Zeit immer mal vermehrt, dass
irgendwie eine Gehaltsrange gepostet wird.
Aber ist immer noch
sehr selten.
Weil das kann halt wieder alles heißen.
Das kann auch 50 Cent über
Mindestlohn heißen.
Ein starkes Wir-Gefühl.
Familiäres Betriebsleben. Auch bei so einem Laden
hab ich meine Ausbildung gemacht, Leute.
Die haben auch immer erzählt, wir sind eine Familie
und ganz dicke und so.
Letztendlich war das ja immer nur ein Trick.
Ja, und das ist es letztendlich.
Change my mind.
Aber das ist es letztendlich bei allen Läden, die sowas erzählen.
Es ist ein Trick, dass du quasi kostenlos
mehr arbeitest.
Weil sobald die Probleme mit dir
haben,
bist du weg vom Fenster.
Also von wegen Familie.
Lass euch
nicht so Zeug erzählen.
Aber ihr kennt ja den Unterschied.
Es ist gut, dass es familiär ist und
dass sie nicht Freunde schreiben, weil
ihr wisst ja, Freunde kann man sich aussuchen,
Familie nicht. Ist da genauso.
Nachhaltigkeit im Alltag.
Nutze unsere Ladesäulen für deine Ehe.
Hey, immerhin. Das wär was.
Da könnte ich kostenlos, wobei da steht nicht,
dass es kostenlos ist.
Da steht nicht, dass es kostenlos ist.
Da könnte ich
zumindest mein Auto
aufladen, weil ich suche nichts Neues.
Es ist nicht wie bei den Amis hier.
Aber du kannst ja auch ganz normal
fristgerecht gekündigt werden, wenn sie bald
keinen Bock mehr auf dich haben.
Das ist im Prinzip
immer ein Trick,
die Leute dazu zu bringen,
sich mehr mit dem Laden zu identifizieren,
vielleicht auch mehr zu machen, als sie eigentlich müssten.
Umso mehr familiär
erzählt wird, umso einseitiger ist das
in der Regel.
Okay, ja.
Stellanzeige ist nicht schlecht.
Aber so
hundertprozentig,
dass ich sagen würde, oh ja,
da will ich unbedingt hin,
ist es auch nicht. Ich denke,
es ist was für Leute,
also wenn das was,
wenn ich mich mit PHP genug auskennen würde,
ich denke, es ist was für Leute,
die schon in dem Bereich was gemacht haben
und
da auch richtig scharf drauf sind,
hier auf PHP-Entwicklung und vielleicht auch
E-Commerce-Zeug. Dann ist das bestimmt
sicher nice. Ansonsten,
auch wenn da viel geschrieben wurde,
springt bei mir nicht der Funke über.
Also ich würde mal sagen, 6 von 10.
Jetzt schätzt du meins sogar 7 von 10.
Ja, 6,5.
Okay, 6,5 von 10.
Wir sollten die Stellanzeigen jetzt
mal raten am Ende.
Weil manche finde ich ja richtig gut
und immer wenn ich darüber nachdenke,
welche war denn zuletzt richtig gut,
fällt mir immer keiner ein. Also die letzte
Stellanzeige, die ich ganz cool fand,
war so eine
kurze, knackige, ich weiß nicht mal welche
das war. Die hatten wir das letzte Mal auch.
Da habe ich auch gesagt, ich finde es gut,
dass die nicht erstmal einen halben Roman über sich
selbst schreiben und dann war das Ganze auch recht
kurz und knackig. Okay.
Weiter, was haben wir denn hier noch?
Ein Senior Softwareentwickler testing
IoT, Docker, IT Support. Moment.
Das ist ja wieder alles.
Was wollt ihr denn jetzt eigentlich haben?
Senior Softwareentwickler
ist okay. Testen in gewisser
Weise auch. Man kann entwickeln für
IoT. Docker gehört irgendwie dazu.
Aber IT Support?
Das gehört auf jeden Fall
nicht dazu.
Oh, was habe ich da gesehen?
Rohre. Ich habe viele
Rohre gesehen. Kann man die Bilder noch ein
bisschen nehmen? Rohre.
Äh.
Ich wollte das Bild mit den Rohren
sehen. Ey, das geht.
Schon wieder.
Stepstone-Keckel, Alter.
Rohre.
Über-Bären-IO.
Immerhin
trendige
IO-Domain.
IO-Domain heißt bestimmt auch
Startup oder sowas in der Richtung.
Würzburg. Aha.
Da wäre ich fast gelandet.
Ein paar Tage später hätte ich dort unterschrieben.
Also nicht bei Bären in Würzburg.
Noch mal das Versuch.
Keine Chance.
Ja.
Das ist in zwei Minuten durchgelesen.
Und das Gute ist, wisst ihr, das Wichtigste
steht schon gleich mal dabei.
Was es an Kohle geben kann.
Okay, also was wollen denn
Bären? Dienstleistung.
Vom Gerät bis zur
Darstellung erfasst er dann.
Die hätten bestimmt Freude an meinem
automatisierten
Kellerautomatisierungs
Wasserdrucksystem.
Das fänden die bestimmt toll.
Erinnern
ihr euch noch dran? Das haben wir im Stream teilweise gebaut.
Ich hab mir so eine
smarte
Ventilsteuerung
gekauft bei Amazon.
Hab den
Microcontroller ausgelötet, der
da drauf war und hab einen
D1 Mini drauf gelötet mit
Tasmota.
Ventil.
Guck mal ob wir das finden.
Es kann aber auch sein,
dass ich das gelöscht habe.
Da ist es doch.
Hier. Smartes
Ventil Chip Transplantieren.
Da hätten die bestimmt
ihre Freude dran.
Wir schließen das jetzt mal.
Alter hatte ich da noch dicke Finger von. Wann ist das?
Vor zwei Jahren. Guck mal.
Da war einfach meine Hand und meine Finger doppelt
so dick wie jetzt.
Und da hatte ich schon ein bisschen abgenommen.
Ja, also das ist so ein Ding womit du
quasi so Ventile steuern kannst.
Da ist ein Motor drin.
Und das haben wir ausgebaut.
Also aufgemacht, ausgebaut und
einen
ESP
dran gelötet. Und das ist mittlerweile
unter das Motor drauf geflasht. Das ist bei mir
mittlerweile im Keller und funktioniert
seit Jahren gut.
Okay, was haben die sonst noch am Start?
Du designst und implementierst neue Module im Bereich
Gerätemanagement.
Du agierst
als technischer Problemlöser.
Du trägst aufgrund deiner Erfahrung
wesentlich zur Stabilität.
Also,
langjährige Erfahrung im Bereich Softwareentwicklung.
Verfügst du bei Erkenntnissen im Bereich Java, Spring Boot,
Restschnittstellen, SQL und Docker.
Okay, immerhin mal ein bisschen konkreter,
aber auch super
vage noch.
Das sind alles Riesenthemen.
Warum Restschnittstelle drinsteht? Wahrscheinlich weil
manche Leute das immer noch für ein Buzzword halten. Dabei ist
der Rest eigentlich fast schon wieder out.
Ne, out kann man nicht sagen,
aber
ja,
es ist halt einfach da.
Du kennst dich gut mit Clean Code.
Ja, da sind wir. Chat!
Also, wenn ich mich mit was auskenne, dann Clean Code,
oder? Das sieht man in jedem
Podcast-Stream.
Cleanest Code. Ich mach nicht einfach nur Clean Code,
ich mach Cleanest Code.
Sowas hier zum Beispiel. Guckt mal.
Ich zeige euch mal Cleanest Code überhaupt.
...
Warum habe ich dreimal Visual Studio offen?
Äh, Visual Studio Code offen.
Egal. Guckt mal hier.
Cleanest. Absolut cleanest.
Cleanest Code ever hier.
Also ich finde, das ist die cleanste Form Validation,
die jemals jemand in JavaScript
gemacht hat.
Kann man auch gut lesen, oder?
Vor allem auch überhaupt nicht dupliziert in
die gleiche Sache zweimal.
Nur der cleanste Code bei mir.
Okay, Flexibilität.
Aha!
Okay, immerhin
steht da ein
Betrag. Wobei ich ganz
ehrlich sagen muss, für einen Senior
Softwareentwickler 50k
ist jetzt
70k würde ich sagen, geht in Ordnung.
Wobei
du da gerade Frankfurt Finanzbranche
deutlich mehr bekommen kannst.
Also da weiß ich's halt.
Paar von unseren Senior
Devs und Architekten
und so, die kriegen auch schon fette
Stonkskohle.
Aber 50k ist denn doch ein bisschen
wenig für eine Senior Stelle, finde ich.
Finde ich, ja.
Sicherlich Frage, wo das ist in Deutschland.
Das ist ja auch noch mitten in Hessen.
Also für
eine Senior Dev Stelle würde ich sagen,
ist das bisschen wenig.
Das geht so irgendwie...
Da finden sie vielleicht jemanden für.
Aber dafür eher nicht.
Ja.
Und zumal die wahrscheinlich auch gar nicht
freiwillig dann 70k bezahlen wollten,
sondern irgendwie...
Das ist auf jeden Fall zu wenig.
Zusätzlich betriebliche Altersverfahren.
Moderner Arbeitsplatz in unserem hellen
und gut ausgestatteten Büroräumen
inklusive Dachterrasse
für den Feierabend.
Feierabend bin ich daheim.
Kostenloser Kaffee, Tee. Wo ist der Obstkorb?
Startup Flair.
Ich glaube das ist nicht nur Startup Flair, das ist ein Startup.
Flache Hierarchien. Ja gut,
die haben tatsächlich flache Hierarchien. Die haben wahrscheinlich einfach
Flache.
Kurze Entscheidungsregion. Arbeiten außerhalb des Elfenbeinturms.
Regelmäßige Team...
Bogenschießen.
Alter, wird gesnipert.
Go-Kart Race ETC.
ETC.
Okay.
Setze... Das wäre was
für so einen Intelligenztest.
Setze diese Reihe logisch fort.
Bogenschießen.
Go-Kart Race. Was kommt als nächstes?
Kletterpark.
Genau daran habe ich auch gedacht.
Genau, ohne Scheiß.
Genau war mein Gedanke.
Kletter... Bowling
vielleicht danach.
Bungee Jumping.
Interessiert.
Ich weiß nicht.
5 von 10.
Die ist nicht super schlecht.
Die ist aber sehr...
Der Funke springt nicht über.
5 von 10.
Begeisterung erhält sich in Grenzen.
Auf englische Stellenanzeigen habe ich keinen Bock.
Heute.
Netzwerkadministrator.
Okay, das hat vorhin jemand gepostet.
Ist derjenige noch da?
Keine Rede von Remote.
Nee, nix.
Hybrid.
Home.
Homeoffice möglich.
Doch.
Aber steht halt gar nichts zu da.
Am Ende sind die so Startup-Flair-mäßig unterwegs,
dass da nichts sich tut.
Man weiß es nicht, ja.
Da wird im Vorfeld immer viel versprochen.
Trotzdem 5 von 10.
So, das Alibi Homeoffice steht hier überall drin.
Ob die es ernst meinen,
weiß man nicht.
Wir wollen ihnen aber auch nichts unterstellen,
also gehen wir von außen, sie meinen es ernst.
Kollege hat diese Stelle vor kurzem überarbeitet.
Ich glaube, da kommen wir heute nicht zu.
Müssen wir mal schauen.
Netzwerkadministrator.
MWD.
Comline.
HR4U.
Wie viele dieser Portale gibt es eigentlich?
Leute, ich glaube, wir brauchen auch...
Es wird Zeit für den Job...
Wie nennen wir das Ding?
JobChamp kann keiner aussprechen.
RecruitChamp.
Der RecruitChamp.
Wir brauchen auch sowas.
Danke für die Subs, Leute.
Ich habe bestimmt wieder welche übersehen.
Mal kurz.
Nee, habe ich nicht.
Ecstasy, danke für den Sub, falls ich sie nicht erwähnt habe.
Wo bist du her?
Bewertest du nur Stellenanzeigen?
Heute schon, ja.
Aber das ist nicht das einzige, was ich mache auf Twitch.
So.
Heute haben wir mal
einen Netzwerkadministrator
am Start für den Rechenzentrumsbetrieb.
Okay, das ist selten
was in der Richtung.
Das sind wirklich viele.
Was machst du hier ansonsten?
Ich empfehle dir,
wenn du es wissen willst,
guck dir mal auf meiner Archivseite
einfach hier so die letzten Streamtitel an.
Da weißt du es.
Ich glaube, es gibt kaum einen Bereich
aus so
IT-Technik grob, den wir nicht schon mal
irgendwie im Stream gestreift haben.
Wir haben alles schon mal
in irgendeiner Art und Weise zumindest
ein bisschen gemacht.
Microcontroller-Entwicklung,
Web-Entwicklung,
Linux-Bastel-Kram,
Zeug zusammengelötet, Web-Assembly-Kram
programmiert, alles.
Wir haben irgendwie alles schon mal
Cobol, wir haben sogar fucking Cobol mal ausprobiert.
LED-Leisten,
Heimautomatisierung, alles.
Haben wir schon mal irgendwie gestreift.
Okay, es gibt ein Bereich, das haben wir noch nie gestreift,
zwei Sachen, zwei Sachen.
SAP und Oracle.
Wobei, Oracle haben wir
schon gestreift,
als ich mich nicht für das Free Tier
anmelden konnte, weil
sie meine Kreditkarte
nicht akzeptiert haben.
Das Einzige, was wir
auf Oracle gestreift haben.
Nein, das haben wir noch nicht gemacht, aber
funktionale Programmier-Sachen haben wir schon gestreift.
Ich meine, ich kann nicht wirklich
alles im Detail gemacht haben, aber ich sag mal so,
Themenbereich haben wir wirklich
nicht gemacht.
Wir haben hier DVB-C Receiver geflasht,
Smart Home Geräte,
Controller aus- und eingelötet,
Windows 98 ausprobiert.
Wir haben alles schon mal, jedes Bereich mal irgendwie
gestreift. AWS nicht, aber
wie gesagt, Thema Cloud und Kubernetes
und so hatten wir auch schon öfters.
Ansible Terraform.
Okay, Kernel-Entwicklung haben wir nicht gemacht, das stimmt.
Ich time-oute nicht selbst,
Leute, das müssen die Mod-Gis machen.
Und ich glaube,
wir haben gerade keine Mod-Gis da.
Dementsprechend gibt's
auch kein Time-Out jetzt.
Mod-Check.
Keine Mod-Gis da. Und wo sind
die eigentlich alle?
Ich meine, ist ja nicht schlimm.
Der Chat benimmt sich ja.
Kannst du gute Bücher
zum Thema Kubernetes empfehlen? Ich habe nicht
ein Kubernetes Buch.
Das stimmt. Das haben wir noch nicht gemacht.
So generell auch was Richtung
Service Mesh. Das haben wir nicht gemacht, ja.
Also ich glaube, ich habe noch nicht
ein Buch zum Thema Kubernetes gelesen.
Ich kann dir aber was empfehlen
zum Thema Kubernetes
lernen. Kennst du Minikube?
Wenn nicht,
guck dir mal Minikube an.
Da hast du einen lokalen
Single-Node-Cluster und kannst
damit rumbasteln.
Das finde ich ist besser zum Lernen, wie
alle Tutorials. Tutorials sind
zusätzlich dabei. Ist nice.
Ach, hast du Timeout eingelöst?
Ach komm, dann
will ich mal nicht so sein.
Dann...
Seit wann hat Twitch denn das
Autocomplete für Benutzername abgeschafft?
Ja.
Selbstlos as fuck.
Alles klar.
Ne, ne, ne.
Ich suche keinen Job gerade. Ich habe meinen Job
erst gewechselt. Letztes
Jahr im April.
Falls dich dieses Thema
interessiert, da habe ich tatsächlich
auf YouTube ein paar Videos zugemacht.
Als ich...
Vor vier Monaten...
Ja.
Da habe ich ein paar Videos zugemacht.
Probezeit,
generell, als ich da meine
Probleme hatte mit
Kündigung, mein letzter Arbeitstag,
Bewerbung geschrieben und sowas.
Beziehungsweise, nicht Bewerbung geschrieben ist
das Falschwort.
Vorstellungsgespräche gehabt und sowas.
Okay.
Ich denke mal, dass ich
mich nicht so auf die
Technik bewegen kann.
Okay.
Ich frag mal, was ist das?
Ersatzwerkadministrator für den
Rechenzentrumsbetrieb.
Das finde ich mal ganz cool, dass wir so
eine richtige Oldschool
Turnschuh-Adminstelle haben.
Wir wissen alle,
dass es die gibt.
Weil irgendjemand muss
die Rechenzentren dieser Welt
Wie der Frasier am Start ist, der bleibt auch da.
Schon die Abschlussprüfung von diesem Jahr gesehen.
Ne, hab ich nicht.
Wir können uns die aber eh nicht im Stream angucken.
Wir können uns die höchstens randomized, anonymisiert,
dass es keine Copyright-Sachen verletzt, im Stream angucken.
Also, zeigt mal her, wo ist hier, Comline.
Comline, das kenn ich, der Name sagt mir irgendwas.
Oder doch nicht?
Unsicher.
So, also.
Okay, erstmal halbe Seite Selbstbeweihräucherung, das ist normal.
Oh nein, ich hab da schon sowas gespottet gerade,
was mich schon wieder, wo ich schon wieder keinen Bock drauf hätte.
SAP, Microsoft Automatisierung, Microsoft Automatisierung.
Och, muss es denn, muss es sein, muss es Microsoft sein, muss es SAP sein?
Was hast du gegen Software aus Pakistan?
Ich dachte, das ist von, von, äh, von Peter aus dem indischen Callcenter.
Also aus dem Microsoft Gold Premium Support Callcenter aus Indien.
Nicht aus Pakistan.
Ach, du meinst, ja, ja, ich weiß, ich weiß.
Sind doch bestimmt die gleichen Leute.
Morgens SAP-Programmierer, abends Callcenter-Scammer.
Erstmal Anydesk installieren lassen bei den Leuten.
Und dann selbst...
Ich glaube, jetzt weiß ich, wo das herkommt.
Kann das sein, dass SAP vielleicht ihre Leute dort in, in, in Pakistan oder Indien,
ich wusste übrigens gar nicht, dass sie dort entwickeln, ja.
Ähm, vielleicht werden die auch generell mit Google Pay-Karten, mit Google Store-Karten bezahlt.
Daher kommt diese, dieser Hang zu Google Payment-Karten.
Wäre eigentlich ein gutes Geschäftsmodell, oder?
Ich hätte mich früher auch in Microsoft Store Points bezahlen lassen.
So zu Xbox 360-Zeiten, wo ich gefühlt jeden Mist gekauft habe an Games.
Also, deine Aufgaben.
Jetzt lass uns das mal ernsthaft angucken.
Was gibt's denn hier noch?
Du erweiterst das bestehende Infrastruktur-Team, stellst den Betrieb unserer Rechenzentrum-Kunden-Infrastruktur sicher.
Gut, Bob, das, wirklich, passt ja zusammen.
In Zusammenarbeit mit anderen Teams entwickelst du die Infrastruktur weiter und gewährleistest ein Unterbringungsvermögen.
Gut, sehr allgemein, aber, ja, passt ja dazu.
Planung, Konfiguration, Betrieb der LAN-Infrastruktur, HP und Cisco in den Rechenzentrums sowie in den Kundenumgebungen.
Durchführung von kontinuierlichen Performance- und Stabilitätskontrollen.
Habe ich euch schon mal die Spanning-Tree-Geschichte erzählt mit Cisco?
Ah, bestimmt habe ich euch schon mal die Spanning-Tree-Geschichte erzählt.
Wo wir im Rechenzentrum damals, wo ich noch beim Provider gearbeitet habe,
wo wir mal irgendwie, fragt mich nicht, was eine Stunde Ausfall hatten wegen Spanning-Tree,
aber ich weiß gar nicht, wie lange das dauert, ich weiß gar nicht, wie lange das dauert,
also, sowas sollte man testen, bevor man das in kritischer Netzwerk-Infrastruktur macht,
deswegen ist das sehr sinnvoll, sowas durchzuführen.
Analyse und Lösung von komplexen Inzidenz, Second and Third Level.
Okay, der zentral bereitgestellten Dienst in den Rechenzentren und Ableitung von Verbesserungsmaßnahmen.
Ja, gut, logisch, gehört da ja irgendwie dabei.
Planung und Administration von Kommunikation.
Kommunikationsnetzen, Provider-Management, damit ist quasi gemeint,
wenn man irgendwelche, vermute ich mal zumindest, damit irgendwelche Dienstleister hat,
die für ein Sachen betreiben, dass das irgendjemand auch koordinieren muss.
Konfiguration und Administration in den Bereichen LAN und WAN inklusive Konzeption,
Weiterentwicklung neuer Sicherheitskonzepte und schon wieder Dokumentation.
Die haben auch noch nichts von meiner Methode gehört anscheinend.
Bearbeitung von CVE-Security-Events sowie Erarbeitung und Umsetzung von Security-Events innerhalb von Kundenumgebung,
Sicherstellung, okay, ich muss mal positiv hervorheben,
auch wenn das alles ein bisschen sehr trocken geschrieben ist und das ja so super formell alles ist,
aber ich muss mal eine positive Sache hier anmerken.
Es passt alles, was hier steht, zu dem, was sie suchen.
Und das ist weit davon entfernt, normal zu sein.
Leider.
Also gefühlt haben die meisten Stellenanzeigen mindestens die Hälfte der Punkte,
die in dem, was sie eigentlich suchen, drin stehen, wenig bis gar nichts mit dem, was sie eigentlich suchen, zu tun.
Also das muss man hier mal positiver hervorheben.
Das, was sie hier suchen und das, was die Anforderungen haben, das passt irgendwie zusammen.
Dein Profil, eine Ausbildung oder Studium, okay, Netzwerk, Rechenzentrum und Administration.
Leute, meint ihr, bei denen würde zählen?
Dass ich das mal eine ganze Weile gemacht habe, aber das jetzt schon über 10 Jahre her ist, länger, 2011 oder so.
Ich meine, ich habe das mindestens 5 Jahre gemacht, aber es ist schon ewig her.
Ne, ich will das nicht machen, ich meine nur, ob die das, also ich habe nicht vor, mich zu bewerben aktuell, ja.
Ich bin da eigentlich ganz happy, wo ich bin.
Aber ob das heute noch jemanden interessieren würde, dass ich mal vor über 15 Jahren,
Sachen verkabelt habe und Playcenter eingebaut habe, wo mir der Arm bald abgefallen ist bei.
Und wo sich ein Kollege seinen Zeh fast abgesprengt hat, mit einem Dell-Server, der ihm auf den Fuß gefallen ist, ohne Sicherheitsschuhe.
Naja.
Ja, der hat bei einem, wir ziehen Hardware um, bauen alte Hardware aus, der hat einen Dell-Server gepackt,
also so einen ollen DL-380, 2HE.
Ja, diese Dinger, heute sind die, heute sind die grün, früher waren die eigentlich alle so grau-rot und so ein Ding,
voll beladen mit Festplatten, wenn dir das so aus Traghöhe runterfällt, mit der Kante auf deinen Fuß.
Was wird denn so ein Ding wiegen, gut bestückt?
30 Kilo, 40 Kilo?
Das ist schwerer, als es auf den ersten Blick aussieht, das wiegt schon ein bisschen was.
Das war Real-Life-Server-Crash, ja.
Ja, so sehen die Dinger eben von innen aus.
Sehen heute noch so aus, wie damals.
Das sind übrigens alles RAM-Riegel hier.
Wir hatten schon für über 15 Jahren Kisten mit 2 Terabyte RAM.
Die waren aber teuer as fuck.
Da gab es, es gab IBM Plates mit einem Terabyte RAM.
Und die haben, glaube ich, das Stück damals irgendwie 32.000 Euro oder so gekostet.
Also quasi, du kannst dir ein Auto verkaufen.
Ja.
Achtung, es fällt...
Schmerzhaft.
Muss man da Sicherheitsschuhe tragen?
Nö, muss man nicht.
Deswegen hat er auch keine Sicherheitsschuhe an.
Wäre halt sinnvoll gewesen.
Dann hätte sich nicht sein Zehhalb abgesprengt mit dem Server.
Genau, es heißt ja auch Turnschuhe admin.
Nicht Sicherheitsschuhe admin.
Muss man denn jetzt die Sicherheitsschuhe tragen, nach dem Vorfall?
Tatsächlich hat man damals,
...dort wo ich gearbeitet habe, damals,
Nach keine Retrospektive und Lessons learned daraus abgeleitet, wie man so schön sagt.
Weil die Leute einfach weiter in ihren Turnschuhen rumturnen lassen.
Was in irgendeiner Art und Weise auch okay ist, weil es ist nie wieder sonst vorher und noch nachher sowas passiert.
Okay, sie suchen jemanden Berufserfahrung, das verstehe ich.
Die wollen nicht, dass irgendwelche Noobs an ihren, in ihre Infrastruktur rumdoktert.
Nicht so wie unser ehemaliger San-Admin.
Der hat es ja zu einem eigenen Video auf meinem Channel gebracht.
Ich mache es kaputt und gehe Mittag essen.
Gute Kenntnisse Netzwerkarchitekturen HP und Cisco, Kenntnisse Firewall Befugnis...
Das ist noch ein Ding?
Okay, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Macht Checkpoint auch moderne Firewalls?
Bestimmt.
Kein Plan.
Ich kenne bloß noch von Checkpoint, kenne ich noch von meiner Ausbildung, Firewall 1 hieß dieses Ding.
Und das Webinterface war geil.
Ja, Leute, haben wir noch alte Checkpoint-Enjoyers, die das noch kennen?
Das Webinterface war übrigens falsch, das war eine Windows-only-Anwendung.
Kennt das noch jemand?
Sieht nice aus.
Man könnte sagen, vielleicht bessere Usability als manche Webinterfaces heute.
Sieht heute genauso aus, ja, wundert mich nicht.
Die haben doch einfach nichts dran geändert.
So sah das aus.
Ich gehe davon aus.
Das Checkpoint heute ein bisschen modernere Sachen hat.
Das war die erste Firewall, mit der ich im Business-Enterprise-Umfeld in Kontakt gekommen bin.
Checkpoint mit diesem komischen Webinterface.
Es sah schon nicht mehr so aus.
Die Software ist bestimmt älter als ich und mit Sicherheit ist die älter als du.
Checkpoint, die Firewall 1, das war glaube ich, wenn ich da historisch richtig liege,
die allererste Stateful-Firewall, die es gab.
Also das war quasi eine richtige Big-Innovation damals.
Wäre heute gar nicht mehr ohne möglich.
Ohne Connection-Tracking.
Hat man heute nicht andere Firewalls?
Ja, ich habe auch in den letzten Jahren, Jahrzehnten kann man fast schon sagen,
wenig von Checkpoint gehört.
Okay, Know-How im Bereich LAN, SAN, Storage, VMware und Azure.
Okay, einfach noch so ein paar Random-Sachen dazu eingeworfen, warum nicht?
Berufsbereitschaften, circa einmal pro Monat, das ist ja nix.
Sofern die ordentlich vergütet werden.
30 Tage Urlaub im Jahr, Entwicklungsmöglichkeit, Jobberatung, IT at Home Programm.
Was können Sie besorgen und was können Sie für die Privatkarte besorgen?
Okay.
Neuesten Technologien, modernen Arbeitsplatz, Equipment, familiäres, schon wieder.
Du, oh, guck mal, hier haben wir ein Video sogar.
Du, oh, guck mal.
Mittelständisches Unternehmen, Flachengaschinen, sehr kurze Entscheidungswege.
Wisst ihr, was ich mich bei diesen Sachen immer frage ist,
juckt das dich als Arbeitnehmer wirklich so, wie die ihre interne Struktur da haben?
Also das ist vielleicht, könntest du sagen, oh ja, nice,
aber das ist nix, was irgendwie großartig meine Entscheidungen beeinflussen würde.
Das schreiben aber viele rein, wie ist das vollkommen egal, ehrlich gesagt.
Solange der Laden läuft,
soll mir das recht sein?
Arbeiten bei einem der besten Arbeitgeber in der ITK-Branche.
Mag sein, auf solche Sachen würde ich allerdings trotzdem nix geben,
wenn es in der Stellenanzeige steht.
Das ist genauso, wie gefühlt 90% dieser Unternehmen,
wobei, das hat nachgelassen, ja, aber 90% der Unternehmen
früher in den Stellenanzeigen drinstehen hatten,
dass sie Marktführer im Bereich XY sind.
Okay, brauchen wir mal, ich hoffe, das Video ist nicht zu cringe.
Wupp, wupp, wupp.
Wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp.
Moment, das ist aber nett, das sieht aber...
Das war mal ein Haus, wo vier Wohnungen, wo mehrere Wohnungen darin zu vermieten waren.
Die haben einfach das ganze Haus gemietet, oder?
Man guckt aber instinktiv immer dahin.
Ja, ich improvisiere auch, ne? Ich bin hier auf alle vorbereitet.
Das wird eh nix.
Hört sich sehr motiviert an.
Naja, zum Thema Wohnung habe ich euch ja schon mal im Video was erzählt.
Storage System, was im Wohnzimmer steht.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, das müssen wir analysieren.
Habe ich da eine mechanische Tastatur gesehen?
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, aber wenn ich mir die Switches angucke...
Richtige Hackermen am Start hier.
Da weißt du schon, die wissen, was sie machen.
Also ich...
Hm?
Christoffer?
At?
Def?
At? Host?
Okay, at Def ist wahrscheinlich, was, wo sie da ihre Umgebung in den Prompt rein...
encoded haben.
Nicht verkehrt.
Ansible Test!
Highly productive, hier.
Produktiver Einsatz.
Ansible Test, so würde ich das auch machen.
Es gibt ja den Spruch, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr den kennt.
Eine Testumgebung hat jeder.
Ne, Moment.
Jetzt habe ich den Spruch verkackt.
Ich habe den Spruch verkackt.
Vergiss es. Jetzt muss ich ihn auch nicht mehr bringen.
Das wäre eigentlich so sinngemäß gegangen, irgendwie.
Eine Testumgebung hat jeder.
Mancher hat auch eine Produktion.
Aber das ist jetzt einmal verkackt.
Das ist nicht mehr lustig.
So, also was haben wir denn hier noch?
Der Christoffer hat zumindest einmal anscheinend ein ordentliches Terminal am Start.
Chatge, was ist das für ein Terminal?
Ist das das Microsoft Terminal im Fullscreen?
Von der Schriftart und dem Terminal würde ich sagen, das ist...
Oder ist das...
Oder ist das ein ordentliches Terminal?
Das ist die Frage der Fragen.
Windows 11 Paints Jam, wenn es ein ordentliches Terminal ist, dann...
Ist das iTerm?
Vielleicht?
Geh weiter.
Ich glaube, alle von uns haben eine große Passion für die Arbeit.
Und man merkt das.
In moderner HR-Sprechweise brennen die für das Thema.
Da geht vieles einfach besser.
Man weiß auch so, jeder Kollege, jede Kollegin weiß, wo wer seine Stärken und Schwächen hat.
Wir sind deswegen gut und vielleicht sogar mit Abstand gehören wir zu den Besten.
Okay.
Kleine, kleine Story am Rande.
Auf solche Standort-Dinger.
Ich sage nicht, dass es bei denen nicht stimmt.
Moment, der hat Keck als Nachname gehabt, wirklich?
Haha.
Keck, wait.
Das ist mal, das ist mal ein guter Nachname.
Keck, weh.
Ähm, ja.
Kleine Story am Rande.
Also, ich will nicht sagen, dass es nicht stimmt, was die sagen.
Ich kann euch nur erzählen, wie das damals war.
Bei dem Laden, wo ich meine Ausbildung gemacht habe, die haben sie im Internet auch geschmückt mit.
Wir sind hier ein ganz toller internationaler Provider mit Standorten in Frankfurt, Wien, Köln.
London, Barcelona, Rom, New York, die ganze Welt war drauf, ja.
Und wisst ihr, was damit gemeint war?
Nicht wirklich Standorte, so wie man sich das vorstellt, so mit einem Gebäude und Mitarbeitern und sonst was.
Die haben irgendwo in irgendeiner Ecke von Barcelona einen Switch in irgendeinem Hotel stehen gehabt oder sowas.
Also.
Das war komplett...
Es war nicht gelogen, aber es war halt schon sehr optimistisch ausgedrückt.
Und da habe ich das beste Foto aller Zeiten von Netzwerkequipment gesehen.
Schade, dass ich das nicht für die Nachwelt erhalten habe.
Ich habe ein Foto gesehen von diesem Switch in Barcelona.
Das war...
Könnt ihr euch nicht vorstellen.
Das war ein Rack im Keller.
Und der Fußboden war Gras.
Das war quasi irgendeine...
Die haben eine Laube da drüber gebaut.
Da war früher Gras.
Und die haben einfach der...
Die haben einfach ein Dach drüber gemacht.
Eine Mauer.
Also die haben einfach eine Mauer drum gebaut.
Ein Dach drauf und haben dann ein Rack reingestellt.
Da war immer noch...
Da waren immer noch Rasenreste auf dem Boden.
Das war quasi kein ordentlicher Boden.
Das war Erde.
Erde mit einer Mauer drum.
Und da stand eine Palette in der Ecke.
Aber ein Rack stand da.
Was ich jetzt nicht mehr so genau aus dem Kopf weiß, ist, ob das Rack selber quasi auf dem Erdboden stand.
Also auf dem Gras.
Oder ob sie das wenigstens irgendwie auf so ein paar Fliesen gestellt haben.
Das war eine der abenteuerlichsten Konstruktionen überhaupt.
Gut und vielleicht sogar mit Abstand gehören wir zu den Besten, weil wir nicht zu groß sind.
Für mich ist Comline ein Teil meiner Familie.
Und ich habe ganz viele Kollegen, die mir sehr viel nähern.
Die mir sehr viel näher stehen als manche Bekannte.
Weil ich einfach so viel...
Ja gut, das stimmt.
Ich meine, du hast mit den Leuten auf der Arbeit halt den ganzen Tag was zu tun.
Aber manche Bekannte siehst du gefühlt einmal im Jahr.
Ob sie da Bugs eingeschliffen haben.
Naja, immerhin habt ihr wirklich echte Standorte.
...mit denen zu tun habt und auch schon so viel erlebt habt.
Es gibt dann so einen regelmäßigen Staffellauf.
Die Kollegen, die da mitmachen.
Das macht halt unheimlich Spaß.
Das ist lustig.
Da ist ein Teamgeist da.
Ich habe auch letztens in Frankfurt bei so einem...
Bei so einem...
Ähm...
Lauf-Event mitgemacht.
Hätte ich auch noch vor einem Jahr nicht gedacht, dass ich jemals bei sowas mitmache.
War das Teams?
Oder haben die irgendwas spezielles an?
Ne, ne, ne, ne.
Eindeutig Teams.
Am ersten Tag dachte ich, oh Gott.
Wie lief das Lauf-Event?
Langsam.
Weil ich bin mit einem Kollegen gelaufen und der hat überhaupt keine Übung.
Wir waren super langsam.
Überhaupt nicht die Unterschiede verstanden habe.
Wie, lan, lan.
Es klang alles gleich.
Wenn ich ehrlich sein soll.
Ich habe mich einfach reingefuchst.
Ich habe mich total dafür interessiert.
Ich hatte aber auch die richtigen Coaches, die mich genau...
Weißt du, was ich dir jetzt gerne fragen würde?
Was der Unterschied zwischen WLAN und WLAN ist?
Meinst du nicht, der hatte große Fresse?
Nee.
Der...
Der wollte...
Naja, so habe ich das nicht gesagt.
Ähm...
Der hat sich angemeldet.
Man musste sich für das Event anmelden.
Mit einer Zeit-Prediction.
Und ich glaube, der hat...
Ich glaube, der hat sich mit 6 Minuten-Pace angemeldet.
Und nachdem er sich angemeldet hat, habe ich ihm versucht, irgendwie nahezulegen, dass 6 Minuten-Pace ohne Übung doch schon sehr schnell ist.
Am Ende hatten wir...
Der war gar nicht schlecht.
Er hat mich wirklich da sehr überrascht.
Ich glaube, wir hatten am Ende so 7... 7...
7 Minuten 30 oder so.
Also gar nicht so schlecht für ungeübt.
Also 7 Minuten 30 ist wirklich nicht verkehrt, wenn man...
Wenn man das sonst nicht macht.
Da war ich langsamer, als ich angefangen habe.
Hauland ist das bessere WLAN.
Ja, der Kenner spricht ja.
Es gibt trotzdem keinen Sinn.
Zlan.
Das hört sich an, wie irgend so ein serbischer oder so Vorname.
Okay.
Mitgenommen haben.
Am ersten Tag saßen wir alle hier.
Wir waren noch 8 weitere Azubis.
Und wir haben uns alle...
Wir haben uns alle...
Wir haben uns alle wirklich sehr gut verstanden.
Als ob wir echt aufeinander abgestimmt wären.
Ich krieg viel ein.
Nur 8?
Das ist ja...
Das sind Rookie Numbers.
Der Provider, wo ich meine Ausbildung gemacht habe,
der hat zwischenzeitlich ein Drittel der Mitarbeiter war Azubis.
Kein Spaß.
Wir hatten über 100 Azubis zwischenzeitlich.
Wobei...
Doch, oder?
Ja, doch.
70 oder so.
Billig bezahlt haben.
Das war da wirklich so.
Die haben sich überlegt.
Okay.
Die haben doch schon mehrere Kunden in Deutschland.
Da müssen ab und zu Server hingebracht werden oder sonst was.
Was ist billiger?
Den Azubi in irgendein Auto zu hocken und ein paar Server in den Kofferraum zu laden
und nach Frankfurt fahren zu lassen?
Oder das dort wirklich mit irgendeiner Spedition hinschicken lassen?
Dreimal dürft ihr raten.
Wie oft da die Azubis durch Frankfurt fahren durften.
Beziehungsweise nicht durch Frankfurt.
Das stimmt ja nicht.
Die mussten ja quasi vom Süden in Deutschland.
Mussten ja rauffahren nach Frankfurt.
Die waren bestimmt 6-7 Stunden unterwegs, um Server zu bringen.
Bis sie wieder daheim waren.
Gegenverantwortung.
Ich darf viele Dinge einfach machen.
Klar ist da ein Risiko dabei.
Aber damit schafft man auch einfach sich selber zu entwickeln.
Mein Opa hätte jetzt gesagt, wo gearbeitet wird, fallen Späne.
Ich denke die Kernformel unseres Erfolgs ist, dass wir führen über Vertrauen.
Und nicht führen über Kontrolle.
Und wenn ich gerade Lust habe,
meine Programmieraufgaben auf der Parkbank zu machen,
weil ich das grüne Umfeld für mich brauche.
Klingt gut.
Ob es wirklich so ist, müssten sie beweisen.
Wir glauben es ihnen einfach mal.
Die besten Ergebnisse liefern.
Why not?
Insofern sitzen die Kollegen entweder in den Geschäftsstellen,
denen sie zugeordnet sind, oder zuhause.
Und wir schalten uns dann über Teams zusammen
und kommunizieren fast ausschließlich virtuell.
Wir müssen uns einfach differenzieren,
dass wir immer wieder diese Zufriedenheit,
gezielt managen.
Wir haben ein System auch aufgesetzt,
das regelmäßig zu überprüfen,
anonymisiert über Great Place to Work.
Wo wir auch wieder ausgezeichnet worden sind.
Man macht seinen Job einfach gerne.
Achso, sie haben eine Auszeichnung bekommen.
Wenn du Lust auf spannende IT-Themen hast,
bewirb dich bei uns.
Wir freuen uns auf dich.
Du suchst einen spannenden Arbeitsplatz?
Dann bewirb dich jetzt bei Commerz.
Was? Tinder ist am Ende?
Das ging doch voll klar, das Video.
Da habe ich schon viel nervigere, cringigere Promotion-Videos gesehen
von kleineren Läden.
Also ich muss sagen, die Stellenanzeige
in Kombination mit dem Video,
den würde ich sogar 7,5 von 10 geben.
Ja, fand ich nicht schlecht.
Ja, fand ich echt okay.
Ja, kannst du machen.
Das Problem ist, die Zeit ist schon wieder vorbei.
Alter, was ist denn im Juni los?
Seid ihr alle auf Jobsuche oder was?
Wir haben noch in keinem Monat drei Stellen aus,
also wir haben sogar im letzten Monat immer nur eine gemacht,
drei Stellen aus Stellenanzeigen-Streams gemacht.
Heute war der zweite.
Ah, du kannst schicken, ich mache noch einen.
Guck mal, wir haben so viele noch, die wir uns angucken müssen.
Da müssen wir demnächst noch einen dritten Stellenanzeigen-Stream machen.
Weil zumindest das, was wir da haben, müssen wir noch durchgucken.
Du musst schon konkrete Stellenanzeigen schicken.
Ich kann jetzt nicht alle angucken.
ZephDesk haben wir schon angeschaut, ja.
Ich habe noch nicht alle geschlossen.
Aber das meiste davon haben wir noch nicht geguckt.
Sollen wir mal gucken, ob es neue Updates gibt?
Ich meine, ich habe vor eineinhalb Stunden erst mal ein System aktualisiert.
Das ist Arch.
Da muss es wieder neue Updates geben.
Oh, nein, gibt es nicht.
Ich kann es ja kaum glauben.
Was sagt man denn dazu?
Darf man überhaupt noch Arch by the way sagen,
wenn es nicht alle 90 Minuten neue Updates gibt?
Das Gefühl habe ich bei einigen Unternehmen, ja.
Wo man sich so denkt,
okay, auf der einen Seite suchen sie Leute,
aber auf der anderen Seite
zappeln sie dann so rum und stellen sich so an,
als wollen sie dann doch keine.
Ja, kenne ich.
Letzter Laden, wo ich gearbeitet habe,
also nicht der, wo ich jetzt aktuell bin.
Oh, mein Auge, mein Auge.
Flashbang.
Der war auch so.
Die haben notorisch Leute gesucht,
aber haben sich dann im Recruitment-Prozess so blöd angestellt,
was gar nicht wirklich beispielsweise an meinem alten Chef oder so lag,
sondern an den Gegebenheiten drumherum,
dass die Leute dann wieder keinen Bock hatten, ja.
Zum Beispiel haben sie reingeschrieben,
Homeoffice möglich.
Das erste, was die Bewerber gemacht haben, ist gefragt,
und wie sieht es aus mit Homeoffice?
Ich habe gelesen hier, ihr schreibt explizit rein,
Homeoffice möglich.
Und dann hat man ihnen dann im Vorstell,
oder bei der ersten Anfrage sagen müssen,
ach nee, das steht quasi sinngemäß,
muss man ihnen dann sagen, das steht nur drin,
eigentlich machen wir es gar nicht.
Dann haben die gesagt, ja gut, und tschüss.
Nie wieder was von denen gehört.
Also, da haben sie sich echt unfähig angestellt.
Ja, und beispielsweise in dem einen Team,
wo ich nicht dazugehört habe,
aber wo ich in der Nähe gesessen habe,
von denen weiß ich auch, die haben immer,
die haben Support gemacht, ja,
aber die haben auch immer händeringend Leute gesucht,
auch Leute mit technischem Background,
ja, für den Support,
also es ging nicht irgendwie um Hilfe,
irgendwie, ich muss meine Druckerpatrone wechseln,
nicht so einen Support, ja.
Eher Systemüberwachung und dann halt gucken,
wer ist dafür zuständig und so.
Nicht wirklich klassisch auf First Level.
Zumindest ist es auch egal.
Die haben Leute gesucht,
und ich hatte mir irgendwann mal
die Stellenanzeige angeguckt
und hatte dem damaligen Teamleiter
bestimmt sieben, acht Punkte geschrieben,
was man hätte besser machen können an der Stellenanzeige.
Aus meiner Sicht, weil ich ja jemand bin,
der zumindest mal so grob angesprochen sein sollte
von dieser Stellenanzeige, ja,
und das sie beispielsweise hervorheben sollen.
Sie haben eine Kantine, freie Betriebssystemauswahl,
höhenverstellbarer Schreibtisch,
Smartphones, die du privat benutzen darfst,
alles mögliche, gab immer so ein paar Dinger,
und es hat sich bis zu dem Zeitpunkt,
wo ich dann gekündigt habe,
Jahre später,
nichts an dieser Stellenanzeige geändert.
Und sie haben sich immer die ganze Zeit gefragt,
ja, warum bewirbt sich denn da keiner?
Und die, die sich bewerben,
warum taugen die denn nix?
Keine Ahnung.
Manche wollen es einfach nicht.
Hast du das Gefühl, ja, sie wollen es,
aber dann wollen sie es auch wiederum nicht.
Nee, Obstkorb haben sie auch nicht reingeschrieben.
Das war die 0815. Stellenanzeige,
die du dir vorstellen kannst.
Aber,
bei Technik-Sachen,
hatten sie ganz viel Zeug drinstehen,
womit die eigentlich gar nix zu tun hatten.
Das kam ja auch noch dabei.
Da standen also Sachen drin, wie
Kenntnisse in Zabbix,
Kenntnisse in VMware ESX.
Da haben die überhaupt nix mit zu tun gehabt.
Aber haben sie auch mal reingeschrieben.
Die Stellenanzeige war einfach nur uninspirierte Kacke.
Und ich bin mir sicher,
die hätten zumindest,
wenn sie ein bisschen angepasst hätten,
die hätten zumindest ein paar Bewerber mehr bekommen.
Weil, das Problem war ja auch,
die Bewerber, die sie hatten,
die haben halt alle gesackt.
Die hatten sogar einmal ein Dreivierteljahr da.
Den haben sie dann aus der Probezeit nicht verlängert.
Eben so, boah, das muss er halt mal schaffen.
Ähm,
weil er halt gar nichts geblickt hat.
Und sich auch keine Mühe gegeben hat.
Und wenn sie gescheite Leute gefunden haben,
dann sind die teilweise
nach einem Jahr oder zwei wieder abgehauen,
weil die festgestellt haben,
ja, so toll ist es dann doch nicht
und Schichtarbeit sackt.
Da gebe ich Ihnen recht,
Schichtarbeit sackt auch.
Somit, ja,
fahr mal für eine Nacht nach Frankfurt
und mach da nichts,
einfach für 10 Stunden.
Schichtarbeit ist der übelste Sack.
Zumal, man hätte dieses Leute
damals auch schon bereitschaftsmäßig
von daheim aus machen lassen können.
Die Stellenanzeige war auch so geschrieben,
ja, das, das, das
und unten stand dann, Bereitschaft zur Schichtarbeit.
So als letzter Punkt,
das heißt,
alle, die bis dahin noch nicht abgesprungen sind,
die sind spätestens da abgesprungen.
Man hätte das ein bisschen hervorheben müssen.
Man hätte nicht einfach nur schreiben müssen,
Bereitschaft zur Schichtarbeit,
sondern man hätte hinschreiben müssen,
dass man einen Work-Life-Balance optimierten Schichtplan hat,
was auch immer das heißen soll, ja.
Man hätte zumindest einfach signalisieren sollen,
okay, wir machen uns Gedanken drum,
wie man das so angenehm wie möglich gestaltet.
Man hätte es vielleicht auch genau so reinschreiben sollen.
Aber nix, ja.
Ich hab das dem damaligen Chef gesagt,
als Feedback geschrieben von diesem,
von dem Team, hat's nix getan.
Ich hab's dem neuen Chef als Feedback geschickt,
hat's nix getan.
Ich will nicht sagen, dass ich der ultimative Checker bin,
was die Stellenanzeigen dafür angeht,
aber nachdem ich persönlich jemand bin,
den sie zumindest mal,
der erweiterte Kreis an Leuten,
den sie damit hätten ansprechen wollen,
kann's ja so verkehrt nicht sein.
Ja, es gab ja,
es gab ja sogar zusätzliches Geld für Schichtarbeiten.
Das hätten die alles reinschreiben müssen.
Und gar nicht mal so wenig.
Gar nicht so schlecht.
Und dann wundern sie sich,
dann wundern sie sich,
dass sie nix finden.
Und jetzt hab ich gehört,
so um drei Ecken,
ich kenn ja immer noch Leute,
die bei meinem alten Arbeitgeber arbeiten,
jetzt hab ich gehört,
jetzt haben sie dieses Team aufgelöst,
weil, das war so der Stein des Anstoßes,
weil sie ja schon die ganze Zeit
keine neuen Leute finden
und jetzt, ja,
mein Kollege,
zusammengewechselt bin
zum neuen Arbeitgeber,
auch weg ist und jetzt haben sie zu wenig
und können den Schichtplan nicht aufrecht erhalten.
Ich sag sie, das hat man doch
koppelt sehen.
Zumal er denen sogar noch
ein Jahr Zeit gegeben hat.
Der wollte schon ein Jahr früher abhauen.
Und da haben sie ihn noch beschwätzt
und haben gesagt, ah, wir haben hier ein,
was haben sie ihm damals erzählt?
Wir haben hier einen Fünf-Punkte-Optimierungsplan
und das und das werden wir
alles umsetzen.
Und da haben sie immer noch nichts davon umgesetzt.
Dann hat er gesagt, okay, also Leute,
ich hab euch jetzt nochmal ein Jahr eine Chance gegeben,
hier so die grundlegenden Sachen in den Griff zu bekommen.
Ihr habt weder Leute gefunden, noch an den anderen Sachen
was geändert, noch krieg ich mehr Kohle.
Dann hat er gesagt, ja gut, tschüss.
Und wie sich so,
wie das der Zufall will,
gab's bei dem Laden,
wo ich mich beworben hab,
halt noch eine zweite Stelle,
auf die er sich dann beworben hat
und jetzt sind wir beide da.
Das ist eben das Ding.
Wir haben uns aufgebaut,
so ich nenn's mal als Support-Team
und jetzt, wo die wirklich Leute hatten,
die durchgeblickt haben
und auch nachts, wenn was kaputt war,
selbst fixen konnten, ohne zu versuchen,
irgendwie versuchen mussten, da irgendjemand anderes erreichen zu können,
jetzt haben sie so viel,
das macht überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Die haben sich einfach nur zu unfähig angestellt.
Das ist komplettes Management-Versagen gewesen,
aus meiner Sicht.
Aber bewerbungstechnisch war das eh witzig.
Ich hab mich ja beworben in Frankfurt,
beziehungsweise,
beworben ist schon fast zu viel gesagt.
Ich hab ne Bewerbung
hochgeladen, okay?
Ähm,
nachdem mich ein ehemaliger Kollege,
der dort jetzt arbeitet, angerufen hat.
Und ich hab ne Bewerbung hochgeladen
und zumindest als ich dann da war,
ich hab noch nicht mal ein Anschreiben dabei gehabt.
Meine Bewerbung
wollte ich euch übrigens auch mal zeigen, ne?
Hab ich noch nicht anonymisiert.
Die ist
wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal richtig gut.
Ja. Zumindest,
witzig wie das war, ich war dort,
Vorstellungsgespräch,
3 Stunden Vorstellungsgespräch, Leute.
An richtig trockenem Hals danach.
3 Stunden Vorstellungsgespräch.
Ja, wir haben alles,
das uferte aber auch aus.
Wir wollten erstmal nur Vorstellungs-,
so Kennenlerngespräch machen und haben gleich beide
von Anfang an gesagt, ey,
heute können wir uns noch für nix entscheiden.
Aber danach, nachdem wir das durch hatten,
nach 2 Stunden, haben wir eigentlich beide gesagt,
ja doch, passt.
Und es muss eh schnell gehen, also haben wir dann noch,
Gehalt und Geld und Past
hinten dran gehängt. Hat nochmal ne Stunde gedauert.
Also, dafür waren wir uns danach einig.
Zumindest,
hab ich meinen zukünftigen
Chef damals dann gefragt, so sag mal hier,
ich hab gesehen,
ihr sucht quasi nochmal genau so
ne Stelle, wie kann das sein?
Da meinte er, ja, hier, anderes Team,
sucht auch noch jemand im Linux-Bereich.
Da hatte ich zufälligerweise
die Bewerbungsunterlagen von meinem Kollege
dabei und hab ihm das in die Hand gedrückt.
Und, n Tag später haben sie ihn angerufen,
irgendwie 2 Tage später hat er auch
ein Vorstellungsgespräch und wir haben beide
letztes Jahr, 1. April, angefangen.
Das war wirklich glückliche Fügung, alles.
Dass das so geklappt hat. Bin ich auch
sehr happy drüber, dass das so geklappt hat,
weil mit dem hab ich mich eh gut verstanden.
Und die haben händeringend Leute gesucht,
die waren eigentlich ganz froh,
dass ich quasi noch jemand mitgebracht hab.
Und, und,
das muss man, muss man der Personalabteilung auch
gut erhalten. Die haben so ein
Mitarbeiter-Werben-Mitarbeiter-Programm,
da kriegt man so einen kleinen Bonus für jeden geworbenen Mitarbeiter.
Ist jetzt wirklich nicht die Welt, aber ist nice.
Und die haben es geschafft,
wie auch immer sie das abrechnungstechnisch gemacht haben,
mir den Bonus schon
gut zu schreiben, für was,
wo ich zum Zeitpunkt dessen noch gar nicht
Mitarbeiter dort war. Das ist nicht schlecht.
Warum hattest du die Bewerbungsunterlagen
von deinem Freund dabei?
Ja, weil ich mir gedacht hab,
die haben eine Stelle bei sich auf der, auf der,
auf der Webseite stehen,
die eins zu eins meiner Stelle entspricht,
und anscheinend suchen die zwei.
Und da hab ich die mal mitgenommen,
wir haben da im Vorfeld drüber geredet, da hab ich gesagt,
weißt du was, ich nehm deine Unterlagen einfach mit
und hau die danach an, wie es aussieht,
ob die noch jemand suchen.
Und anscheinend haben sie noch jemand gesucht.
Da hatte ich halt zufällig die
Bewerbungsunterlagen dabei.
Hab ich ihnen in die Hand gedrückt.
Und hat funktioniert, wir haben beide erst im April angefangen.
Und was ich im Nachhinein rausbekommen hab,
äh, was ich im Nachhinein rausbekommen hab,
ist,
dass das andere Team
eigentlich,
also dort wo er jetzt ist, der ist nicht bei mir im Team,
ja, wir haben beim gleichen Arbeitgeber angefangen,
der gibt ja noch mehr, der ist nicht bei mir im Team.
Was ich, was ich im Nachhinein
rausbekommen hab, ist,
dass sein jetziger Chef
die Stellenanzeige
copy-pasted hat von meinem
Chef.
Deswegen war das die gleiche Stellenanzeige.
Es war eins zu eins die gleiche
Stellenanzeige, obwohl sie eigentlich jemand anderes
suchen.
Die haben es copy-pasted.
Da stand auch Blockchain
und sowas drinne. Und ich dachte, ich hab
mir damals ja schon gedacht, als ich Blockchain
gelesen hab, okay, da werden irgendwelche
Buzzword-Dinger um sich geschmissen, aber
muss man ihnen sagen, ihr wisst, ich bin
jetzt in so einem Crypto-Blockchain-Projekt, die haben das
tatsächlich ernst gemeint, aber mein Kollege
macht mit Blockchain und
Crypto-Sachen gar nix.
Der hat einfach copy-pasted seinen Chef.
Haben gesagt, ey, hier, guck mal,
wir suchen auch jemanden im
Linux-Umfeld, hat noch jemand was, ich hab keinen Bock
das zu schreiben oder so.
Copy-pasted, reingehauen, hat ja auch
funktioniert.
Aber ich muss sagen,
ich bin echt happy, dass das so geklappt hat, wie es
geklappt hat.
Dass wir da beide hinkonnten.
Ach ja, und was auch witzig war, ich hatte so
einen Kennenlern-Termin
mit allen
neuen Leuten aus der IT,
die im April angefangen haben.
Da saßen wir da so,
mit,
weiß nicht, 13,
14 Leuten, also nicht in der IT,
das ist falsch, für alle neue Leute,
die im April in unserer
Abteilung angefangen haben, so muss man sagen.
Da saßen wir irgendwie mit
13, 14, 12, 13, 14
Leuten oder so da rum, sondern da stellen wir
uns, haben uns alle vorgestellt und gesagt, ja, hallo,
ich bin der Max,
ich war vorher da und da bei XY,
da kommt mein Kollege dran,
hallo, ich bin da sowieso, ich war vorher bei XY
und auf einmal,
zwei Leute
später sagt ein Typ,
den wir gar nicht richtig kannten,
aber der mir schon irgendwie bekannt vorkam,
ja, hallo,
ich bin der XY, ich war
vorher auch bei XY,
Moment, daher kenne ich dich
also, du kamst mir schon die ganze Zeit
so bekannt vor.
Da saß einfach random jemand, der vorher
beim gleichen Laden war wie ich.
Ich hatte nicht viel mit dem zu tun,
aber ich dachte mir schon
die ganze Zeit, der kommt mir irgendwie bekannt vor.
Also,
mein neuer Arbeitgeber hat wohl hart
abgeworben bei meinem alten Laden.
Wenn allein schon in unserer Abteilung
drei Leute gesessen haben, die dort
vorher waren
und jetzt, und jetzt ja noch einer kommt
von dort
im Oktober,
dann sind wir vier.
Ne, der alte Laden ist groß, der ist auch
richtig groß.
Die haben mehr als vier.
Ja.
Das war schon echt geil,
das hat schon echt ganz glücklich hingehauen.
Ich habe meinem Chef auch gleich schon gesagt,
übrigens, einen habe ich noch, ja, also einen kenne ich noch,
falls wir nochmal Linux-Leute suchen in nächster Zeit.
Und wir suchen in nächster Zeit Linux-Leute,
weil zwei bei uns
bald in Rente gehen.
Da wisst ihr, wie alt manchmal manche unserer Systeme sind.
Die waren bei der Einführung noch dabei.
Und die gehen in Rente
und dann muss das ja,
naja, es wird wahrscheinlich nicht
direkt neu besetzt,
aber es wird was ähnliches ausgeschrieben,
weil die brauchen ja Leute.
Wir haben tatsächlich
Windows-Admins gesucht, bis
keine Ahnung, vor zwei, drei Wochen
oder so. Einen.
Aber das
wurde noch nicht öffentlich ausgeschrieben.
Das haben sie intern
besetzt.
Okay, Leute,
22.15, Bad-Kid-Time. Ich muss morgen
früh aufstehen, nach Frankfurt fahren.
Alles klar.
Wir hören uns. Nächster Stream,
nicht gleich wieder Stellen anzeigen,
aber wir werden das alles hier abarbeiten.
Irgendwie.
Nächster, übernächster,
überübernächster Stream oder so.
Ja.
Bad-Kid-Time.
Wir hören uns. Macht's gut. Bis denn.
See you.